hello everyone welcome to this amazing
video in artificial intelligence Basics
artificial intelligence or AI as it is
popularly known is a broad term that
refers to the development of intelligent
agents that can perform tasks that
typically require human intelligence
such as visual perception speech
recognition problem solving and decision
making these agents are not only able to
perform these tasks but they can also
learn from experience and improve over
time from medical diagnosis to
predicting the stock market and making
trades from improving the accuracy of
self-driving cars to creating realistic
virtual assistants better voice
resistant and intelligent robots AI has
the capability to greatly enhance our
daily lives simply put AI is the future
with the pace of technological change
accelerating every year it's becoming
increasingly important to have a deep
understanding of AI and its application
as you continue to advance in AI
research and development there will be
an increasing number of opportunities
for professionals who possess these
expertise whether you are a developer a
data analyst or just someone who's
curious about the future of technology
learning AI is an investment in your own
future as well as in your future of your
society as a whole so let's dive in and
start exploring the Incredible World of
artificial intelligence and now we are
thrilled to present our AI bootcamp that
is designed to equip you with the
knowledge and skills you need to thrive
in this fast-paced and ever evolving
field in this six months intensive and
immersive learning experience you will
have the opportunity to dive head first
into the subject matter gaining hands-on
experience and building a strong
foundation in AI we believe in a
practical approach where you will work
on 25 plus Hands-On projects across
various industry verticals providing you
with real world experience what sets a
boot camp apart is a partnership with
caltex CDMA ensuring academic excellence
and Industry recognition by successfully
completing the boot camp you will earn a
prestigious certificate and up to 22 CU
credit it's from caltex ctma validating
your expertise in the field so are you
ready to embark on this transformative
Journey are you ready to unlock the
power of AI and take your career to new
heights if so enroll in our AI bootcamp
today and become part of the AI
Revolution the course link is mentioned
in the description box below but before
we begin let's check out what one of our
Learners has to say about our courses
artificial intelligence has already
become a part of our lives
and I wanted to learn more about it
the course is helping me tremendously in
my upskilling journey
hi I'm Daniel dick I'm 66 years old and
I'm semi-retired and live in California
with my wife and son
it's childhood I've had a strong
interest in science and technology I was
fascinated by the way systems worked
internally and how algorithms performed
but after 40 years of working in
technology sector I could no longer work
it hit me hard
I looked at how well my daughter was
doing as a software engineer my daughter
became my inspiration upskill and over
the years I pursued various courses in
different fields of computer science
I realized that technology has the power
to change the world
I worked rigorously in the healthcare
sector as a technocrat
and I know technology can revolutionize
it
I wanted to know how it could be used in
the healthcare sector or leather sectors
so I could contribute to those domains
whenever I start something of my own the
course is practical all of my new
details and concepts are explained in
the most simplistic manner
the curriculum was well designed
considering Learners from different
backgrounds it was an amalgamation of
practical labs in theory
program focuses on building a
problem-solving attitude in Learners the
course is helping me tremendously in my
upskilling journey and solving real life
problems whatever the problem is you can
either solve it or learn to solve it by
upskilling yourself and now we will have
a local agenda for our AI Basics
tutorial starting with what is
artificial intelligence then we'll have
an audio of AI roadmap for 2023 then
we'll have an explanation of different
types of artificial intelligence then
we'll showcase the top 10 AI
applications and after this we'll see
the future of artificial intelligence
and after that we'll have exploration of
machine learning starting with
introduction to machine learning then
overview of different types of machine
learning then we'll have comparison of
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning and after that we
will Deep dive into linear regression
analysis and its application in R and
then when have introduction to logistic
regression and its implementation in
Python and then we have comparison of
linear regression and logistic
regression and then we'll see machine
learning techniques and tools starting
with classification and machine learning
then we'll explore decision Tree in
machine learning and then we'll showcase
the top 10 AI tools for 2023 and after
that we'll highlight the top 10 AI
robots in 2023 and after that you place
an exciting artificial intelligence
project ideas for 2023 and after this
we'll have an introduction to the top 10
AI companies for 2023 and the discussion
over the career opportunities in
artificial intelligence for 2023 it's a
weekend and John decided to watch the
latest movie recommended by Netflix at
his friends place
before heading out he asked Siri about
the weather and realized it would rain
so he decided to take his Tesla for the
long journey and switch to autopilot on
the highway
after coming home from the eventful day
he started wondering how technology has
made his life easy
he did some research on the internet and
found out that Netflix Siri and Tesla
are all using AI
so what is AI
AI or artificial intelligence is nothing
but making computers-based machines
think and act like humans artificial
intelligence is not a new term John
McCarthy a computer scientist coined the
term artificial intelligence back in
1956 but it took time to evolve as it
demanded heavy computing power
artificial intelligence is not confined
to just movie recommendations and
virtual assistants
broadly classifying there are three
types of AI artificial narrow
intelligence also called weak AI is the
stage where machines can perform a
specific task Netflix Siri chat Bots
spatial recommendation systems are all
examples of artificial narrow
intelligence
next up we have artificial general
intelligence referred to as an
intelligent agent's capacity to
comprehend or pick up any intellectual
skill that a human can
we are halfway in a successfully
implementing this space IBM's Watson
supercomputer and gpt3 fall under this
category and lastly artificial super
intelligence
it is the stage where machines surpass
human intelligence you might have seen
this in movies and imagine how the world
would be if machines occupy it
fascinated by this John did more
research and found out that machine
learning deep learning and natural
language processing are all connected
with artificial intelligence
teen learning a subset of AI is the
process of automating and enhancing how
computers learn from their experiences
without human health
machine learning can be used in email
spam detection medical diagnosis Etc
deep learning can be considered a subset
of machine learning it is a field that
is based on learning and improving on
its own by examining computer algorithms
while machine learning uses simpler
Concepts deep learning works with
artificial neural networks which are
designed to imitate the human brain this
technology can be applied in face
recognition speech recognition and many
more applications
natural language processing popularly
known as NLP can be defined as the
ability of machines to learn human
language and translate it chat Bots fall
under this category
artificial intelligence is advancing in
every crucial field like healthcare
education robotics banking e-commerce
and the list goes on like in healthcare
AI is used to identify diseases helping
healthcare service providers and their
patients make better treatment and
lifestyle decisions
coming to the education sector AI is
helping teachers automate grading
organizing and facilitating parent
Guardian conversations
in robotics ai-powered robots employ
real-time updates to detect obstructions
in their path and instantaneously design
their routes artificial intelligence
provides Advanced data analytics that is
transforming banking by reducing fraud
and enhancing compliance
with this growing demand for AI more and
more Industries are looking for AI
Engineers who can help them develop
intelligent systems and offer them
lucrative salaries going north of one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
future of AI looks promising with the AI
Market expected to reach 190 billion
dollars by 2025. artificial intelligence
is reshaping Industries and transforming
the way we will leave and work it
encompasses a wide range of Technologies
including machine learning deep learning
natural language processing computer
vision and many more with its ability to
analyze vast amount of data and make
Intelligent Decisions AI has become a
game changer across various domains hi
everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel this AI roadmap guides
you in navigating the path towards
building a successful career in
artificial intelligence the ultimate
goal of artificial intelligence is to
create intelligent missions that can
perform complex tasks exhibit human-like
intelligence and contribute positivity
to society AI presents exciting career
opportunity in various Industries and
sectors roles like AI engineer data
scientists NLP Engineers computer vision
Engineers AI research scientists robotic
engineers and many more offers exciting
prospects for working with cutting ITS
Technologies and making an impact
through artificial intelligence
Innovation according to Glassdoor the
average reported salary of an AI
engineer in the United States is around
000 per year however in India it is
still like per annum leading companies
worldwide are fully aware of the immense
value of AI and are actively pursuing
skilled AI Engineers to contribute to
their research development and
implementations of AI technology among
this top companies are Google Microsoft
Amazon Goldman Sachs apple and JPMorgan
Chase therefore top companies hiring AI
engineer provide excellent opportunity
for aspiring professionals on that note
eliminate your career with our Ai and ml
course developed in partnership with
Purdue University and IBM gain expertise
in high demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning charge GPT
generative Ai explainable Ai and more
Unleash Your Potential initial and
unlock exciting opportunity in the world
of AI and ml this course cover tools
like python tensorflow Keras charge apt
open AI gym matplotlib and many more so
hurry up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details our
Learners have experienced huge success
in their careers listen to their
experience finally simply learn course
reviews Link in the description box
without any further delay let's dive
into the topic now if you decide to
become an AI engineer here are the steps
you can follow to achieve your goal
firstly obtain a strong foundation in
mathematics and programming gain a
strong foundation in creating mathematic
Concepts like linear algebra calculus
and probability theory in addition to
that it is crucial to occur Mastery of a
programming languages like python
commonly used in Ai and become
proficient in coding then earn a degree
in a relevant field that means earn a
bachelor's or master degree in computer
science data science AI or a related
field to gain a comprehensive
understanding of AI principles and
techniques next gain knowledge in
machine learning and deep learning to
become a AI engineer develop similarity
with ML algorithms neural networks and
deep learning Frameworks examples
tensorflow by torch to train and
optimize models using real world data
set followed by that work on practical
projects gain hands-on experience and
showcase your skills by working on AI
projects moreover build a portfolio of
projects demonstrating your ability to
solve EI problems embracing potential
employers then stay updated with the
latest advancements stay updated with
the latest trends and research in AI a
rapidly involved fields and expanding
your knowledge by reading research
papers participating in online courses
and workshops and joining AI communities
next collaborate and network engage with
AI communities attend conference
participate in online forums to connect
with Professionals in this field
collaborating with others can enhance
your learning experience and open new
opportunities later seek internships or
entry-level positions gain practical
experience through AI internships or
entry-level roles in industry or
research institutions this provides
valuable exposures and help developed
your skills finally continuously learn
and adapt in the rapidly involving field
of AI stay updated on new developments
explore specialized areas and embrace
emerging Technologies and tools to
pursue a career as an AI engineer now
that we have covered the essential steps
to become an AI engineer let's explore
the necessary programming languages and
algorithms for aspiring AI Engineers so
mastering programming languages like
python are Java and C plus plus is vital
for acquiring Proficiency in AI this
language is enables you to construct a
deploy models effectively additionally
it would help if you gain a thorough
understanding of machine learning
algorithms such as linear regressions K
nearest neighbors name base and support
Vector missions these languages and
algorithms are fundamental tools in the
field of AI they will enable you to
develop and Implement effective
artificial intelligence models now let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced huge success in
their career you need to keep updating
your skills the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty were
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional and now we were thrilled to
present our AI bootcamp that is designed
to equip you with the knowledge and
skills you need to thrive in this
fast-paced and ever-evolving field in
this six months intensive and immersive
learning experience you will have the
opportunity to dive head first into the
subject matter gaining hands-on
experience and building a strong
foundation in AI we believe in a
practical approach where you will work
on 25 plus Hands-On projects across
various industry verticals providing you
with real world experience what sets a
boot camp apart is a partnership with
Caltech cdme ensuring academic
excellence and Industry recognition by
successfully completing the boot camp
you will earn a prestigious certificate
and up to 22 CU credits from caltex ctma
validating your expertise in the feed so
so are you ready to embark on this
transformative Journey are you ready to
unlock the power of AI and take your
career to new heights if so enroll in
our AI bootcamp today and become part of
the AI Revolution the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
first let's understand what really is
artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is the science
of building intelligent machines from
vast volumes of data
this data can be structured
semi-structured or unstructured in
nature
AI systems learn from past experiences
and perform human-like tasks artificial
intelligence enhances the speed the
season and effectiveness of human
efforts
AI uses sophisticated algorithms and
methods to build machines that can make
decisions on their own deep learning and
machine learning are the two subsets of
artificial intelligence so you need both
machine learning algorithms and deep
learning networks to build intelligent
systems
AI is now being widely used in almost
every sector of business such as
Transportation Healthcare banking retail
entertainment and e-commerce
now let's look at the different types of
artificial intelligence
so AI can be classified based on
capabilities and functionalities
under capabilities there are three types
of artificial intelligence
they are narrow AI General Ai and super
AI
under functionalities we have four types
of artificial intelligence reactive
machine limited memory theory of mind
and self-awareness let's look at them
one by one
first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on capabilities
so what is narrow AI
narrow AI also known as vki focuses on
one narrow task and cannot perform
Beyond its limitations
it aims at a single subset of cognitive
abilities and advances in that Spectrum
applications of narrow AI are becoming
increasingly common in our day-to-day
lives as machine learning and deep
learning methods continue to evolve
Apple Siri is a simple example of an
arrow AI that operates with a limited
predefined range of functions
Siri often has challenges with tasks
outside its range of abilities IBM
Watson supercomputer is another example
of narrow AI which applies cognitive
Computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your questions
IBM Watson once outperformed human
contestant Ken Jenkins to become the
champion on the popular game show
Jeopardy other examples of narrow AI
include Google Translate image
recognition software recommendation
systems spam filtering and Google's page
ranking algorithm
next we have General artificial
intelligence or general AI General AI
also known as strong AI has the ability
to understand and learn any intellectual
task that a human can
General artificial intelligence has
received a one billion dollar investment
from Microsoft through open AI it allows
a machine to apply Knowledge and Skills
in different contexts AI researchers and
scientists have not achieved strong AI
so far to succeed they would need to
find a way to make machines conscious
programming a full set of cognitive
abilities
Fujitsu built the K computer which is
one of the fastest computers in the
world
it is one of the most notable attempts
at achieving strong AI
it took 40 minutes to simulate a single
second of neural activity so it is
difficult to determine whether or not
strong AI will be achieved in the near
future
2 is a supercomputer created by China's
national university of Defense
technology
it currently holds the record for CPS at
33.86 petaflops although it sounds
exciting the human brain is estimated to
be capable of one example of
now CPS means characters per second that
A system can process
third in the list of AI that is based on
capabilities we have super AI super AI
exceeds human intelligence and can't
perform any tasks better than a human
the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees AI evolved to be so
akin to human emotions and experiences
that it doesn't just understand them it
evokes emotions needs beliefs and
desires of its own its existence is
still hypothetical some of the key
characteristics of super AI include the
ability to think solve puzzles meet
judgments and decisions on its own
now if you have enjoyed watching this
video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest Technologies also if you have
any questions related to this video
please put it in the chat section A team
of experts will help you address your
questions
moving ahead now we will see the
different types of artificial
intelligence based on functionalities
in this category first we have reactive
machine
a reactive machine is the basic form of
AI that does not store memories or use
past experiences to determine future
actions it works only with present data
they simply perceive the world and react
to it reactive machines are given
certain tasks and don't have
capabilities Beyond those duties
IBM's deep blue which defeated just
Grand Master Gary Castro is a reactive
machine that sees the pieces on hsboden
reacts to them
it cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice
deep blue can identify the pieces on a
chessboard and know how each moves
it can make predictions about what moves
might be next for it and its opponent
it can choose the most optimal moves
from among the possibilities deep blue
ignores everything before the present
moment
all it does is look at the pieces on the
chessboard as it stands right now and
chose from possible next moves
up next we have limited memory
limited memory AI learns from past data
to meet decisions
the memory of such systems is
short-lived
while they can use this data for a
specific period of time they cannot add
it to a library of their experiences
this kind of technology is used for
self-driving vehicles
they observe how other vehicles are
moving around them in the present and as
time passes
that ongoing collected data gets added
to the static data within the AI machine
such as lean markers and traffic lights
they're included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle
Mitsubishi Electric is a company that
has been figuring out how to improve
such technology for applications like
self-driving cars
then we have theory of mind
theory of Mind represents a very
advanced class of technology and exists
as a concept
this kind of AI requires a thorough
understanding that the people and the
things within an environment can alter
feelings and behaviors
it should be able to understand people's
emotions sentiment and thoughts
even though a lot of improvements are
there in this field this kind of AI is
not complete yet
for real world example of theory of Mind
AI is Kismet a robot head made in the
late 90s by a Massachusetts Institute of
Technology researcher Kismet can mimic
human emotions and recognize them both
abilities are key advancements in theory
of Mind AI but Kismet can't follow gazes
or convey attention to humans
Sophia from Hanson robotics is another
example where the theory of Mind AI was
implemented cameras within Sofia's eyes
combined with computer algorithms allow
her to see
she can follow faces sustain eye contact
and recognize individuals
is able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsystem
finally we have self-awareness
self-abariance AI only exists
hypothetically
such systems understand that internal
traits States and conditions and
perceive human emotions
these machines will be smarter than the
human mind
this type of AI will not only be able to
understand and evoke emotions in those
it interacts with but also have emotions
needs and beliefs of its own while we
are probably far away from creating
machines that are self-aware we should
focus our efforts towards understanding
memory learning and the ability to base
decisions on past experiences
so what let me ask you a question which
are the powerful AI assistants that you
have come across please leave your
answer in the comment section below and
stay tuned to get the answer so what are
the top 10 applications of artificial
intelligence social media today AI can
create social media posts for you it can
draft and Target social ads
it can also automate monitoring
and it has powers that most of what you
see in any given social network
Facebook's picture recognition tools
have been popular among users for a
while but the company is constantly
working to make the algorithms better so
that users can browse photos without
relying on tags or other nearby
information it will help to tag people
in photos
Twitter
understanding what needs to recommend to
users on their timelines is one of the
numerous ways Twitter employs AI on its
platform it seeks to provide users with
the most relevant tweets possible for
individualized experience Twitter also
uses AI to combat offensive statements
Instagram artificial intelligence is
used by the platform to improve user
experience filter spam and increase the
effectiveness of targeted advertising
users in the platform can search images
of a specific activity when new event
restaurant food and Discovery
experiences
with the aid of tags and trending
information
automobiles the automotive value chain
which includes manufacturing design
Supply production post-production
driving assistance and Driver risk
assessment systems is successfully
implementing artificial intelligence
Tesla keeps an eye on the driver's eyes
to detect signs of drowsiness and keep
them from dozing off while operating a
vehicle it is primarily used by the
autopilot system to stop drivers from
taking quick power naps while driving
agriculture
Forbes reports that Global spending on
Smart agriculture including artificial
intelligence and machine learning is
projected to Triple to 15.3 million
dollars by 2025. Precision agriculture
often known as artificial intelligence
systems is assisting in enhancing the
overall quality and accuracy of harvest
artificial intelligence technology AIDS
in the detection of pest plant diseases
and under nutrition in firms artificial
intelligence sensors can identify and
Target plants before deciding which
herbicide to use in the area
additional intelligence in gaming the
gaming industry is another area where
artificial intelligence technologies
have gained popularity artificial
intelligence can be utilized to develop
intelligent human-like non-person
characters that can communicate with the
players in order to improve game design
and testing it can also be used to
forecast human behavior the 2014 alien
isolation video game employee artificial
intelligence to follow the player around
all the time two artificial intelligence
systems are used in the game one is the
director artificial intelligence who
frequently knows where you are and the
alien artificial intelligence which is
controlled by sensors and behaviors and
constantly changes the player next comes
a artificial intelligence in healthcare
delays can be the difference between
life and death in the healthcare
industry artificial intelligence in
healthcare has the potential to help
providers in many areas of patient care
and operational procedures enabling them
to build on current Solutions and solve
problems quickly
covid-19 has illuminated the process of
developing vaccine in order to create
and Test new medicines drug
manufacturers are increasingly turning
to artificial intelligence Solutions
like deep learning because there are so
many potential chemical combinations
creating new medications requires
processing a lot of data artificial
intelligence overcomes this difficulty
by utilizing its exceptional performance
with massive amounts of data this
capability results in a higher
production of a pro Pharmaceuticals in a
more rapid less expensive and more
effective research and development
procedure
robotics another area where artificial
intelligence is frequently applied is
robotic AI powered robots employ
real-time updates to detect obstructions
in their path and instantaneously design
their Roots robotics uses artificial
intelligence to make machines more
intelligent and capable of acting in
variety of situations
robots can also sense their environment
or take in its views with the views of
sensor similar to how humans have
primary sensors robotics uses a variety
of sensing technology combined there is
a definite Trend toward mobile
autonomous robots that can intelligently
gather process and manage data in order
to make the best decisions for
manufacturing or production
thank you
AI in banking the use of advanced data
analytics by artificial intelligence
will transform banking in the future by
reducing fraud enhancing compilence
anti-money laundering tasks that would
typically take hours or days can now be
completed in a matter of seconds thanks
to artificial intelligence algorithms
Erica a virtual assistant created by
Bank of America is among the best
instances of artificial intelligence
chatbots in banking applications this
artificial intelligence chatbot can take
care of tasks like updating card
security and reducing credit card
daily life use of artificial
intelligence
autonomous vehicle to teach computers to
think and evolve like humans when it
comes to driving in any environment and
object recognition to prevent accidents
companies like Toyota Audi Tesla use
machine learning algorithms
spam filters now email that we regularly
use features artificial intelligence
that separates out junk emails and sends
it to spam or trash folders allowing us
to see only the filtered material Gmail
a well-known email service has achieved
a filtration capacity of roughly
99.9 percent
next comes facial recognition
facial recognition algorithms are used
by our favorite devices including phones
laptops and personal computers to detect
and identify users in order to Grant
safe access
education sector artificial intelligence
can assist Educators with
non-educational tasks such as
facilitating and automating personalized
messages to students back office duties
such as grading paperwork organizing and
facilitating
routine feedback managing enrollment
courses Etc a student can receive
additional learning resources or
assistance with voice assistance even
without the lecturer or teacher's direct
engagement this lowers the expense of
producing temporary handbooks and makes
it simple to provide answer to
frequently Asked topics
artificial intelligence is most commonly
used in the field of e-commerce during
personalized shopping recommendation
engines are made possible by artificial
intelligence Technologies allowing you
to interact with your customers more
effectively their browsing history
preferences and interests are taken into
consideration while making these
recommendations
it helps you build stronger bonds with
your clients and increases brand loyalty
for instance almost every page of
Amazon's website offers personalized
product recommendations
credit card frauds fake reviews are two
most of the significant issues that
e-commerce companies deal with by
considering the usage patterns
artificial intelligence can help reduce
the possibility of credit card frauds
taking place
many customers prefer to buy a product
or service based on customer reviews
artificial intelligence can identify and
handle fake reviews
what is the answer to the question that
I have asked about artificial
intelligence assistant they can be
Google Assistant Siri Alexa
Etc
moving on
in the area of artificial intelligence
significant advancement have been made
and the results are clear AI is a
flexible tool that is applied across
sectors to improve decision making boost
efficiency and get rid of repeated tasks
researchers are preparing us for a
revolution that will change the world
Forever by looking into the future of
artificial intelligence this revolution
isn't going to happen in a few decades
but in a few years which means that the
clock is ticking for now for businesses
to start embracing AI artificial
intelligence has become a part of our
Lives due to its revolutionary nature
artificial intelligence also faces
numerous debates regarding potential
impacts on individuals although it could
be risky it's also a fantastic
opportunity
it is estimated that the global
artificial intelligence Market will
reach
267 billion dollars by 2027. people are
worrying about losing their jobs as AI
continues to advance because it has
revolutionized Industries across all
sectors but AI has increased the number
of jobs and possibilities available to
individuals across all Industries every
machine needs a person to run it
although AI has replaced certain
occupations it still creates more jobs
for humans
AI can be categorized into three types
firstly weak AI performs specific tasks
like Apple's Siri
General AI performs tasks like a human
super AI is more capable than a human
but both General Ai and super AI are
hypothetical because these Technologies
are not yet developed and research is
going on however the development of such
AI will take a lot of time the
development of AGI will accelerate
within the following 10 years in fact
according to researchers there is a 25
probability that by 2023 AI will
resemble humans when it comes to
thinking capacity additionally the
current data boom computer developments
and improvements in automated methods
and machine algorithms will provide a
solid foundation for platforms with
human level ai ai has occupied crucial
sectors like healthcare
cyber security e-commerce agriculture
robotics education the military system
Finance gaming and many more AI is used
in healthcare to identify diseases
helping healthcare service providers and
their patients make better treatment and
lifestyle decisions
we can say that without AI we couldn't
have made the incredible recent
advancements in fields like robotics
virtual reality
chat Bots face recognition
and autonomous vehicles
smart robot advisors in finance
Insurance legal media and journalism
will deliver instantaneous research or
discoveries in the upcoming years it is
anticipated that artificial intelligence
and machine learning will become more
prominent in the consumer Market which
will immediately affect how well web
development functions virtual assistants
or chat Bots will provide professional
advice other advantages include
strengthening governance through better
decision-making processes shortening
time to market for r d initiatives and
streamlining transportation and supply
chain Networks given all these scenarios
AI is all set to revolutionize every
sector in the near future given that it
is expected to impact 60 percent of
firms artificial intelligence will
continue to spread deeper into a wide
range of Industries in the upcoming
years it is currently driving
development in our smart devices cars
and favorite apps in the coming years AI
will invade every aspect of our life and
eventually surpass human intellectual
capacity it won't be long before
artificial intelligence becomes a common
part of our everyday lives
as it becomes more prevalent it will
allow us to live more efficiently and
improve our lives by increasing their
effectiveness efficiency and
concentration on the primary tasks that
require people's attention AI
Technologies are transforming many
industry sectors artificial intelligence
will change the world for the better
Sci-Fi movies and books depict a future
with sentiment machines capable of
interacting with humans and Performing
tasks just like people would what if we
told you that this future is already a
reality all of this is already made
possible by Machine learning machine
learning is a science of programming
machines to think and act like humans
without being specifically programmed to
we already use machine learning in our
daily life without knowing it email spam
recognition spell check even the YouTube
video recommendation which brought you
here are implemented using machine
learning machine learning uses
algorithms to learn tasks these
algorithms are fed with data from which
they learn to perform these tasks this
means that over time as changes in data
occur we don't need to reprogram our
application just let it find patterns
and learn from the new data machine
learning is a subset of artificial
intelligence which is a science concern
with imparting human-like intelligence
onto machines and creating machines
which can sense reason act and adapt
deep learning is a sub-branch of machine
learning which is inspired by the
working of the human brain machine
learning is leading us to a future where
machines can learn and think and has
opened us a whole new plethora of job
opportunities
this was a brief intro to machine
learning
about a life with life without machine
or someone who doesn't know anything
about machine learning or artificial
intelligence he or she might think that
it is only being used in robots or
machines and stuff
which is actually true exported by most
of the Sci-Fi movies nowadays but you
wouldn't believe how much more machine
learning is giving us how much of it we
are using in our daily lives
let's say you need information on any
random topic say a computer
the first place you would check would
definitely be Google right it would
collect all the information on the word
you search for and present it to you
according to relevance if there was no
Google you would have to do it in a very
hard way that is by going through tens
or hundreds of books and articles even
after which you won't find the answer
if we go back four to five years facial
recognition would be a thing only shown
in movies like Mission Impossible or
Terminator or any of the Sci-Fi movies
you pick
but machine learning has made it
possible for Facebook and Instagram to
use this feature for your benefits you
don't have to go through the trouble of
tagging every single person present in a
picture that you have posted Facebook
will automatically recognize the people
in the photo and tag them for you
that saves a lot of time for you doesn't
it
also Siri Cortana Iris all of them would
not be there to help you if there was no
machine learning
now that we know life would be a lot
more difficult without machine learning
let's look into the things that are run
by Machine learning and we are using
them on our daily basis
let's enter the world of gaming PS4s and
Xboxes have introduced virtual reality
glasses which brings a whole new level
of detail into gaming every time your
head Moves In Real World it replicates
the movement in the virtual world
providing an excellent gaming experience
then there is gesture control gaming
wherein machine learning tracks your
body movement and makes a corresponding
movement in the game
finally in the game FIFA your opponent
tends to adapt based on the kind of
strategy or gameplay you follow
that is again done by Machine learning
I'm sure you must have shopped a lot
from Amazon so let's look into some of
the places Amazon makes use of machine
learning
let's say you buy a formal t-shirt on
Amazon now as you buy it it suggests you
formal shoes ties Blazers and apparels
that go with what you have bought
that's the recommendation system powered
by Machine learning again the price on
every product that you see on Amazon is
wearing every moment based on demand
that's being done by Machine learning
algorithms
then comes customer segmentation
customer segmentation is one of the most
crucial thing for all the e-commerce
platforms machine learning helps them
differentiate between customers based on
what they buy how frequent are they and
their reviews
this helps the companies to make sure
that their customers are taken care of
and the needs are being fulfilled
now let's talk about an app that you use
on a daily basis to reach office on time
yes it's Uber cabs once you have
traveled with Uber you must have noticed
that it suggests you the places you
might want to go based on your previous
Journeys when you're taking a share how
does the app make sure that the cab you
get is travel by the same route you want
to travel in there are so many factors
like the distance the traffic the
ratings all of it is taken care of by
Machine learning
for the past five minutes we have been
talking about how machine learning is
improving our lives where all it is
being used I have probably said machine
learning 100 times already
I think it's about time that I tell you
what machine learning actually is
let's take an ordinary system that you
currently are using it can't do much
except from the basic operations that
you already know about now let's add
artificial intelligence or for a
Layman's point of view let's keep the
same machine the power to think on its
own that is what machine learning
basically is it's an application of
artificial intelligence that provides
systems the ability to learn on their
own and improve from experience without
being programmed externally
so if your computer had machine learning
it may be able to play the difficult
parts of a game for you or probably
solve a complicated mathematical
equation for you
that could be really helpful let's dive
in a little deeper and see how machine
Learning Works
let's say you provide a system with the
input data that carries the photos of
various kinds of fruits now you want the
system to figure out what are the
different fruits and group them
accordingly so what the system does it
analyzes the input data then it tries to
find patterns patterns like shapes size
and color
based on these patterns the system will
try to predict the different types of
fruit and segregate them finally it
keeps track of all such decisions it
took in the process to make sure it's
learning the next time you ask the same
system to predict and segregate the
different types of fruits it won't have
to go through the entire process again
that's how machine Learning Works
now let's look into the types of machine
learning
machine learning is primarily of three
types first one is supervised machine
learning as the name suggests you have
to supervise your machine learning while
you train it to work on its own it
requires labeled training data next up
is unsupervised learning wherein there
will be training data but it won't be
labeled
finally there is reinforcement learning
wherein the system learns on its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised Learning Works look at the
pictures very very carefully the monitor
depicts the model or the system that we
are going to train
this is how the training is done we
provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of a fruit say an
apple
then we provide another data set which
lets the model know that these pictures
where that of a fruit called Apple
this ends the training phase now what we
will do is we provide a new set of data
which only contains pictures of Apple
now here comes the fun part the system
can actually tell you what fruit it is
and it will remember this and apply this
knowledge in future as well
that's how supervised Learning Works you
are training the model to do a certain
kind of an operation on its own
this kind of a model is generally used
into filtering spam maze from your email
accounts as well yes surprise aren't you
so let's move on to unsupervised
learning now let's say we have a data
set which is cluttered in this case we
have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed this data to
the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it in the
end it categorizes the photos into three
types as you can see in the image based
on their similarities
so you provide the data to the system
and let the system do the rest of the
work simple isn't it
this kind of a model is used by Flipkart
to figure out the products that are well
suited for you
honestly speaking this is my favorite
type of machine learning out of all the
three and this type has been widely
shown in most of the Sci-Fi movies
lately let's find out how it works
imagine a newborn baby
you put a burning candle in front of the
baby the baby does not know that if it
touches the flame its fingers might get
burnt
so it does that anyway and gets hurt
the next time you put that candle in
front of the baby it will remember what
happened the last time and would not
repeat what it did that's exactly how
reinforcement learning works we provide
the machine with a data set wherein we
ask it to identify a particular kind of
a fruit in this case an apple
so what it does as a response it tells
us that it's a mango but as we all know
it's a completely wrong answer so as a
feedback we tell the system that it's
wrong it's not a mango it's an apple
what it does it learns from the feedback
and keeps that in mind
when the next time when we ask a same
question it gives us the right answer it
is able to tell us that it's actually an
apple that is a reinforced response so
that's how reinforcement learning works
it learns from his mistakes and
experiences this model is used in games
like Prince of Persia or Assassin's
Creed or FIFA wherein the level of
difficulty increases as you get better
with the games
just to make it more clear for you let's
look at a comparison between supervised
and unsupervised learning firstly the
data involved in case of supervised
learning is labeled as we mentioned in
the examples previously
we provide the system with a photo of an
apple and let the system know that this
is actually an apple
that is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future predictions
now unsupervised learning does not
require any kind of label data because
its work is to look for patterns in the
input data and organize it
the next point is that you get a
feedback in case of supervised learning
that is once you get the output the
system tends to remember that and uses
it for the next operation
that does not happen for unsupervised
learning and the last point is that
supervised learning is mostly used to
predict data whereas unsupervised
learning is used to find out hidden
patterns or structures in data
I think this would have made a lot of
things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning
now let's talk about a question that
everyone needs to answer before building
a machine learning model
what kind of a machine learning solution
should we use
yes you should be very careful with
selecting the right kind of solution for
your model because if you don't you
might end up losing a lot of time energy
and processing cost
I won't be naming the actual Solutions
because you guys aren't familiar with
them yet so we will be looking at it
based on supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning
so let's look into the factors that
might help us select the right kind of
machine learning solution
first factor is the problem statement
describes the kind of model you will be
building or as the name suggests it
tells you what the problem is for
example let's say the problem is to
predict the future stock market prices
so for anyone who is new to machine
learning would have trouble figuring out
the right solution but with time and
practice you will understand that for a
problem statement like this solution
based on supervised learning would work
the best for obvious reasons
then comes the size quality and nature
of the data if the data is cluttered you
go first unsupervised if the data is
very large and categorical we normally
go for supervised learning Solutions
finally we choose the solution based on
their complexity
as for the problem statement wherein we
predict the stock market prices it can
also be solved by using reinforcement
learning but that would be very very
difficult and time consuming unlike
supervised learning
algorithms are not types of machine
learning in the most simplest language
they are methods of solving a particular
problem
so the first kind of method is
classification which falls under
supervised learning classification is
used when the output you are looking for
is a yes or a no or in the form a or b
or true or false like if a shopkeeper
wants to predict if a particular
customer will come back to his shop or
not he will use a classification
algorithm
the algorithms that fall under
classification are decision tree knife
base random Forest logistic regression
and KNN
the next kind is regression this kind of
a method is used when the predicted data
is numerical in nature like if the
shopkeeper wants to predict the price of
a product based on its demand it would
go for regression
the last method is clustering
clustering is a kind of unsupervised
learning again it is used when the data
needs to be organized
most of the recommendation system used
by Flipkart Amazon Etc make use of
clustering
another major application of it is in
search engines the search engines study
your old search history to figure out
your preferences and provide you the
best search results
one of the algorithms that fall under
clustering is k-means
now that we know the various algorithms
let's look into four key algorithms that
are used widely we will understand them
with very simple examples
the four algorithms that we will try to
understand are K nearest neighbor linear
regression decision tree and knife pace
let's start with our first machine
learning solution K nearest neighbor
K nearest neighbor is again a kind of a
classification algorithm as you can see
on the screen the similar data points
form clusters
the blue one
the red one
and the green one there are three
different clusters
now if we get a new and unknown data
point it is classified based on the
cluster closest to it or the most
similar to it
K in KN is the number of nearest
neighboring data points we wish to
compare the unknown data with
let's make it clear with an example
let's say we have three clusters in a
cost to durability graph first cluster
is of footballs
the second one is of tennis balls
and the third one is of basketballs
from the graph we can say that the cost
of footballs is high and the durability
is less the cost of tennis balls is very
less but the durability is high and the
cost of basketballs is as high as the
durability
now let's say we have an unknown data
point
we have a black spot which can be one
kind of the pause but we don't know what
kind it is
so what we'll do we'll try to classify
this using KNN so if we take K is equal
to 5 we draw a circle keeping the
unknown data point in the center and we
make sure that we have five balls inside
that Circle in this case we have a
football a basketball and three tennis
balls now since we have the highest
number of tennis balls inside the circle
the classified ball would be a tennis
ball
so that's how K nearest neighbor
classification is done
linear regression is again a type of
supervised learning algorithm this
algorithm is used to establish linear
relationship between variables one of
which would be dependent and the other
one would be independent
like if we want to predict the weight of
a person based on his height weight
would be the dependent variable and
height would be independent
let's have a look at it through an
example
say we have a graph here showing a
relationship between height and weight
of a person
let's put the y axis as h
and the x-axis as weight
so the green dots are the various data
points
these green dots are the data points
and D is the mean squared error that is
the perpendicular distances from the
line to the data points
are the error values
this error tells us how much the
predicted values vary from the original
value
Let's ignore this blue line for a while
so let's say if this is our regression
line
you can see the distance from all the
data points from this line is very high
if we take this line as a regression
line the error in the prediction will be
too high
so
in this case the model will not be able
to give us a good prediction
let's say we draw another regression
line here like this
even in this case you can see that the
perpendicular distance of the data
points from the line is very high
so the error value will still come as
high as the last one
so this model will also not be able to
give us a good prediction
so what to do
so finally we draw a line which is this
blue line so here we can see that the
distance of the data points from the
line is very less
relative to the other two lines we drew
so the value of D for this line will be
very less
so in this case if we take any value on
the x-axis the corresponding value on
the y-axis will be our prediction
and given the fact that the D is very
low our prediction should be good also
this is how regression works we draw a
line a regression line that is in such a
way that the value of D is the least
eventually giving us good predictions
this algorithm that is decision tree is
a kind of an algorithm you can very
strongly relate to it uses a kind of a
branching method to realize the problem
and make decisions based on the
conditions
let's take this graph as an example
imagine yourself sitting at home getting
bored you feel like going for a swim
what you do is you check if it's sunny
outside so that's your first condition
if the answer to that condition is yes
you go for a swim if it's not sunny in
the next question you would ask yourself
is if it's raining outside so that's
condition number two
if it's actually raining you cancel the
plan and stay indoors if it's not
raining then you would probably go
outside and have a walk
that's the final note
that's how decision tree algorithm works
you probably use this every day it
realizes a problem and then takes the
decisions based on the answers to every
conditions
Knight base algorithm is mostly used in
cases where a prediction needs to be
done on a very large data set it makes
use of conditional probability
conditional probability is the
probability of an event say a happening
given that another event B has already
happened
this algorithm is most commonly used in
filtering spam mails in your email
account
let's say you receive a mail
the model goes through your old spam
Mill records
then it uses base theorem to predict if
the present male is a spam mail or not
so p c of a is the probability of even C
occurring when a has already occurred p
a of C is the probability of event a
occurring when C has already occurred
and P C is the probability of even C
occurring and Pa is a probability of
event a operating
let's try to understand Knight base with
a better example Knight base can be used
to determine on which days to play
cricket
based on the probabilities of a day
being rainy windy or sunny the model
tells us if a match is possible
if we consider all the weather
conditions to be event a for us
and the probability of a match being
possible even C
so the model applies the probabilities
of event A and C into the base theorem
and predicts if a game of cricket is
possible on a particular day or not
in this case if the probability of C of
a is more than 0.5 we can be able to
play a game of cricket if it's less than
0.5 we won't be able to do that that's
how nivas algorithm works let's look at
the definition of each of these learning
techniques
supervised learning uses labeled data to
train machine learning models labeled
data means that the output is already
known to you
the model just needs to map the inputs
to the outputs an example of supervised
learning can be to train a machine that
identifies the image of an animal
below you can see we have our trained
model that identifies the picture of a
cat
unsupervised learning uses unlabeled
data to train machines unlabeled data
means there is no fixed output variable
the model learns from the data discovers
patterns and features in the data and
Returns the output here is an example of
an unsupervised learning technique that
uses the images of vehicles to classify
if it's a bus or a truck
so the model learns by identifying the
parts of a vehicle such as the length
and width of the vehicle the front and
rear end covers roof hoods the types of
Wheels used Etc based on these features
the model classifies if the vehicle is a
bus or a truck
reinforcement learning trains a machine
to take suitable accents and maximize
reward in a particular situation
it uses an agent and an environment to
produce actions and Rewards the agent
has a start and an end state but there
might be different parts for reaching
the end State like a maze in this
learning technique there is no
predefined target variable an example of
reinforcement learning is to train a
machine that can identify the shape of
an object given a list of different
objects such as square triangle
rectangle or a circle
in the example shown the model tries to
predict the shape of the object which is
a square here
now
let's look at the different machine
learning algorithms that come under
these learning techniques
some of the commonly used supervised
learning algorithms are linear
regression logistic regression support
Vector machines K nearest neighbors
decision tree random forest and knife
base
examples of unsupervised learning
algorithms are key means clustering
hierarchical clustering DB scan
principle component analysis and others
choosing the right algorithm depends on
the type of problem you are trying to
solve
some of the important reinforcement
learning algorithms are Q learning Monte
Carlo sarsa and deep Q Network now let's
look at the approach in which these
machine learning techniques work
so supervised learning takes labeled
inputs and Maps it to known outputs
which means you already know the target
variable
unsupervised learning finds patterns and
understands the trends in the data to
discover the output so the model tries
to label the data based on the features
of the input data
while reinforcement learning follows
trial and error method to get the
desired solution after accomplishing a
task the agent receives an award
an example could be to train a dog to
catch the ball if the dog learns to
catch a ball you give it a reward such
as a biscuit
now let's discuss the training process
for each of these learning methods
so supervised learning methods need
external supervision to train machine
learning models and hence the name
supervised
they need guidance and additional
information to return the result
unsupervised learning techniques do not
need any supervision to train models
they learn on their own and predict the
output
similarly reinforcement learning methods
do not need any supervision to train
machine learning models
and with that
let's focus on the types of problems
that can be solved using these three
types of machine learning techniques so
supervised learning is generally used
for classification and regression
problems we'll see the examples in the
next slide
an unsupervised learning is used for
clustering and Association problems
while reinforcement learning is reward
based so for every task or for every
step completed there will be a reward
received by the agent
and if the task is not achieved
correctly
there will be some penalty used
now let's look at a few applications of
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning
as we saw earlier supervised learning
are used to solve classification and
regression problems for example You can
predict the weather for a particular day
based on humidity precipitation wind
speed and pressure values
you can use supervised learning
algorithms to forecast sales for the
next month or the next quarter for
different products similarly you can use
it for stock price analysis or
identifying if a cancer cell is
malignant or benign
now talking about the applications of
unsupervised learning we have customer
segmentation So based on customer
Behavior likes dislikes and interests
you can segment and cluster similar
customers into a group another example
where unsupervised learning algorithms
are used is customer churn analysis
now let's see what applications we have
in reinforcement learning so
reinforcement learning algorithms are
widely used in the gaming Industries to
build games it is also used to train
robots to perform human tasks profit
estimation of a company if I was going
to invest in a company I would like to
know how much money I could expect to
make so we'll take a look at a venture
capitalist firm and try to understand
which companies they should invest in so
we'll take the idea that we need to
decide the companies to invest in we
need to predict the profit the company
makes and we're going to do it based on
the company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our RND which is
your research and development we have
our marketing we might have the location
we might have what kind of
administrations going through based on
all this different information we would
like to calculate the profit now in
actuality there's usually about 23 to 27
different markers that they look at if
they're a heavy duty investor we're only
going to take a look at one basic we're
going to come in and for Simplicity
let's consider a single variable R and D
and find out which companies to invest
in based on that so when we take our r d
and we're plotting The Profit based on
the r d expenditure how much money they
put into the research and development
and then we look at the profit that goes
with that we can predict a line to
estimate the profit so we draw a line
right through the data when you look at
that you can see how much they invest in
the r d is a good marker as to how much
profit they're going to have we can also
note that companies spending more on R D
make good profit so let's invest in the
ones that spend a higher rate in their r
d what's in it for you first we'll have
an introduction to machine learning
followed by Machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in let's start with our
introduction to machine learning along
with some machine learning algorithms
and where that fits in with linear
regression let's look at another example
of machine learning based on the amount
of rainfall how much would be the crop
yield so here we have our crops we have
our rainfall and we want to know how
much we're going to get from our crops
this year so we're going to introduce
two variables independent and dependent
the independent variable is a variable
whose value does not change by the
effect of other variables and is used to
manipulate the dependent variable it is
often denoted as X in our example
rainfall is the independent variable
this is a wonderful example because you
can easily see that we can't control the
rain but the rain does control the crop
so we talk about the independent
variable controlling the dependent
variable let's Define dependent variable
as a variable whose value change when
there is any manipulation the values of
the independent variables it is often
denoted as Y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be a description the color a dog's
breed gender categorical is limited to
very specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions when we look at a different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervise today
unsupervised means we we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
SIMPLE linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we Harvest them those would be
additional information add into our
model and that's why it'd be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the GDP of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should I buy today housing
cells to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions Cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance I'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory understanding linear
regression linear regression is the
statistical model used to predict the
relationship between independent and
dependent variables by examining two
factors the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation with one dependent and one
independent variable is represented by y
equals m times X plus C and if you look
at our model here we plotted two points
on here X1 and y1 X2 and Y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and next being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever X is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the Y2
minus y1 and X2 minus X1 and finally we
have C which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the
zero axes let's go back and look at an
example we used earlier of linear
regression we're going to go back to
plotting the amount of crop yield based
on the amount of rainfall and here we
have our rainfall remember we cannot
change rainfall and we have our crop
yield which is dependent on the rainfall
so we have our independent and our
dependent variables we're going to take
this and draw a line through it as best
we can through the middle of the data
and then we look at that we put the red
point on the y-axis is the amount of
crop yield you can expect for the amount
of rainfall represented by the Green Dot
so if we have an idea what the rainfall
is for this year and what's going on
then we can guess how good our crops are
going to be and we've created a nice
line right through the middle to give us
a nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this let's look at the intuition
behind the regression line now before we
dive into the math and the formulas that
go behind this and what's going on
behind the scenes
I want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable X and our dependent variable Y
and when X was one we got y equals 2
when X was 2 y was 4 and so on and so on
if we go ahead and plot this data on a
graph we can see how it forms a nice
line through the middle you can see
where it's kind of grouped going upwards
to the right the next thing we want to
know is what the means is of each of the
data coming in the X and the Y the means
doesn't mean anything other than the
average so we add up all the numbers and
divide by the total so one plus two plus
three plus four plus five over five
equals three and the same for y we get
four if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get three
comma four which draws a nice line down
the middle a good estimate here we're
going to dig deeper into the math behind
the regression line now remember before
I said you don't have to have all these
formulas memorized or fully understand
them even though we're going to go into
a little more detail of how it works and
if you're not a math whiz and you don't
know if you've never seen the sigma
character before which looks a little
bit like an e that's opened up that just
means summation that's all that is so
when you see the sigma character it just
means we're adding everything in that
row and for computers this is great
because as a programmer you can easily
iterate through each of the X Y points
and create all the information you need
so in the top half you can see where
we've broken that down into pieces and
as it goes through the first two points
it computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x times Y and
then it takes all of X and adds them up
all of Y adds them up all of x squared
adds them up and so on and so on and you
can see we have the sum of equal to 15
the sum is equal to 20 all the way up to
x times Y where the sum equals 66 this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times X plus the
coefficient C so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
Computing it line by line instead of
trying to you have a huge set of numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope m equals and then the
top part if you read through the
brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum of x times Y which
we computed one line at a time there and
that's just the 66 and take all that and
you subtract it from the sum of x times
the sum of Y and those have both been
computed so you have 15 times 20. and on
the bottom we have the number of lines
times the sum of x squared easily
computed as 86 for the sum minus I'll
take all that and subtract the sum of x
squared and we end up as we come across
with our formula you can plug in all
those numbers which is very easy to do
on the computer you don't have to do the
math on a piece of paper or calculator
and you'll get a slope of 0.6 and you'll
get your C coefficient if you continue
to follow through that formula you'll
see it comes out as equal to 2.2
continuing deeper into what's going
behind the scenes let's find out the
predicted values of Y for corresponding
values of X using the linear equation
where m equals 0.6 and C equals 2.2
we're going to take these values and
we're going to go ahead and plot them
we're going to predict them so y equals
0.6 times where x equals 1 plus 2.2
equals 2.8 and so on and so on and here
the Blue Points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors the best fit line
should have the least sum of squares of
these errors also known as e-square if
we put these into a nice chart we can
see X and you can see Y what the actual
values were and you can see why it
predicted you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
Square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least squared distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
Etc which you want to take away from
this is whatever formula is being used
you can easily using a computer
programming and iterating through the
data calculate the different parts of it
that way these complicated formulas you
see with the different summations and F
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time up until this point
we've only been looking at two values X
and Y well in the real world it's very
rare that you only have two values when
you're figuring out a solution so let's
move on to the next topic multiple
linear regression let's take a brief
look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals M plus X plus C and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just X we have X1 X2 X3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have M1 M2 M3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
M1 times X1 plus M2 times X2 so on all
the way to m to the nth x to the nth and
then you add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part let's
understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing it in
Python if you remember before we were
looking at a company and just based on
its R and D trying to figure out its
profit we're going to start looking at
the expenditure of the company we're
going to go back to that we're going to
predict as profit but instead of
predicting it just on the R and D we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration costs marketing cost and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company is going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic libraries and we're going to
be looking through the data before we do
any kind of linear regression we're
going to take a look at the data to see
what we're playing with then we'll go
ahead and format the data to the format
we need to be able to run it in the
linear regression model and then from
there we'll go ahead and solve it in and
just see how valid our solution is so
let's start with importing the basic
libraries now I'm going to be doing this
in Anaconda Jupiter notebook a very
popular IDE I enjoy because it's such a
visual to look at and it's so easy to
use just any ID for python will work
just fine for this so break out your
favorite python IDE so here we are in
our Jupiter notebook let me go ahead and
paste our first piece of code in there
and let's walk through what libraries
were importing first we're going to
import numpy as NP and then I want you
to skip one line and look at import
pandas as PD these are very common tools
that you need with most of your linear
regression the numpy which stands for
number python is usually denoted as NP
and you have to almost have that for
your SK learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning pandas
although you don't have to have it for
your sklearn libraries it does such a
wonderful job of importing data setting
it up into a data frame so we can
manipulate it rather easily and it has a
lot of tools also in addition to that so
so we usually like to use the pandas
when we can and I'll show you what that
looks like the other three lines are for
us to get a visual of this data and take
a look at it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pi plot as PLT and then
Seaborn as SNS Seabourn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then Seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the Seaborn is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the Amber signed matplot library
in line that is only because I'm doing
an inline IDE my interface in the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook requires I put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read CSV and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end one thousand companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
Supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that I have companies equals
pd.reader underscore CSV and I've
changed this path to match my computer C
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv and then below
there we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the I location and
because this is companies is a PD data
set I can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except up
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so X is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
I'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when I
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an Excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns R and D
spend Administration marketing spend
State profit it even notes that the top
top are column names it was never told
that but pandas is able to recognize a
lot of things that they're not the same
as the data rows why don't we go ahead
and open this file up in a CSV so you
can actually see the raw data so here
I've opened it up as a text editor and
you can see at the top we have r d spend
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carries
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where I can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and Investments and you understand what
349.20 compared to the administration
cost of 136
897.80 so on so on helps to create the
the profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
SNS which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matplot Library dot Pi plot
is PLT which then the Seaborn uses and
we imported the Seaborn as SNS and then
that final line of code helps us show
this in our inline coding without this
it wouldn't display and you could
display it to a file in other means and
that's the matplot library in line with
the Amber sign at the beginning so here
we come down to the single line of code
Seabourn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so I can
just take the comp companies dot core
for coordinates and I can put that right
into the Seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one we have
the columns and the rows we have R and D
spending we have Administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with Administration costs so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark diagonal row that shows that
this is the highest corresponding data
that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column 0 which is R and D spending
column one which is Administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is State and you'll see
under State we have New York California
Florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process New
York it knows how to process a number so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to change that New York
California and Florida and we're going
to change those to numbers that's what
this line of code does here x equals and
then it has the colon comma 3 in
Brackets the first part the colon comma
means that we're going to look at all
the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit is the third row and
in there we're going to take the label
coder and we're going to fit and
transform the X also the third row so
we're going to take that third row we're
going to set it equal to a
transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a New York it has a zero or a one
or a two and then finally we need to do
a one hot encoder which equals one hot
encode or categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data
Force so it's completely set the way we
need it is just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if I go ahead
and just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and I'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different models
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
Y what this is is X is our data going in
that's our RND spin our Administration
our marketing and then Y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test split we take X and
we take y we've already created those X
has the columns with the data in it and
Y has a column with profit in it and
then we're going to set the test size
equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent so twenty percent of the rows
are going to be tested we're going to
put them off to the side so since we're
using a thousand lines of data that
means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting so setting up our
variables but the next step is the next
step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go ahead and
put that code in there and walk through
it so here we go we're going to paste it
in there and let's go ahead and since
this is a shorter line of code let's
zoom up there so we can get a good look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now I don't know if
you call from earlier when we were doing
all the math let's go ahead and flip
back there and take a look at that do
you remember this or we had this long
formula on the bottom and we were doing
all this summarization and then we also
looked at setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor.fit in this case we do X
train and Y train because we're using
the training data X being the data n and
y being profit what we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when I run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals True
Fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a why
predict variable and we're going to put
in the X test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict X test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
I'm in Jupiter in line I can just put
the variable up there and when I hit the
Run button it'll print that array out I
could have just as easily done print y
predict so if you're in a different IDE
that's not an inline setup like the
Jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side is going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when I run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into and where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals M1 times X1 plus M2
times X2 and so on and so on plus C the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope 2
times column 2 variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the N plus C
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus is 8.89 to the power of 2 etc etc
times the First Column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in Co and so we're going to use
this from
sklearn.metrix we're going to import R2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the R2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
why test is the actual values we're
testing that was a 1 one that was given
to us so we know are true the why I
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the R2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model could remember it does have
a random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression the Y linear
regression now that we have come this
far I'm planning to take a closer look
at our cells so that we can estimate
cells in the future how about we hire a
data scientist you can see our two
corporate individuals looks more like
they should be agents or secret agents
some Place discussing how to better
forward their company and so they're
going to come in and ask the data
scientists to come in good idea this
will help us to keep a constant track of
our sales so why do we need linear
regression let's assume that we need to
predict the number of skiers based on
snowfall so this happens to be we've
kind of jumped one business to the next
we're looking at the skiing business
very popular in a lot of areas and it's
based on snowfall a lot of times you
figure you don't have snow you don't
have skiers but can we actually use
something more specific instead of look
it's snowing and instead of saying Hey
look it's snowing we can actually start
drawing graphs and the graph shows that
with an increase in snowfall the
frequency of skiers also increases so
and there's a pretty direct correlation
if you've ever been up to the ski areas
when there's a lot of snowfalls the
skiers All Shook because they know it's
going to be better skiing right
afterwards so it's kind of easy to see
why skiers and snowfall would go
together and usually draws a nice
straight line and you can easily predict
how many skiers and that way you can
also predict how many people you need to
service them how many lifts have up and
running and all the stuff that goes with
running a ski area thus we see that the
number of skiers are directly
proportional to the amount of snowfall
regression models a relation between a
dependent Y and an independent X
variable this is real important to
understand regression because when we
talk about linear regression it's the
basis of almost all our machine learning
algorithms out there and it's usually an
underlying part of the math in our deep
learning so it all starts here with
linear regression and we talk about a
dependent Y and an independent X
variable these are numbers we're usually
talking about floats so we want to have
an actual number value coming out and
that's different than something that's
categorical or we want to know yes or no
true false so regression means we're
looking for a number the independent
variable is known as predictor variable
and dependent variable is known as the
response variable so we have one
predictor variable the amount of
snowfall and one response variable how
many skiers are going to show up and
then we can take this relationship and
it can be expressed as y equals beta
we're going to use the Greek letter beta
and we have beta naught plus beta 1 x 1
and if you continue out it'd be plus
beta 2 x 2 and so on till the nth degree
in this case snowfall is an independent
variable and skiers is a dependent
variable so we kind of had a little
quick overview let's go ahead and talk a
little bit more about what is linear
regression so we're going to go from y
predicting a number of skiers for
snowfall and we looked at the formula a
little bit but let's look a bit closer
at what exactly is going on with linear
regression and the question is going to
come up in an interview what is linear
regression linear regression is a type
of statistical analysis that attempts to
show the relationship between two
variables linear regression creates a
predictive model on any data showing
Trends in data the model is found by
using the least Square method there are
other methods the least Square method
happens to be the most commonly used out
there and we usually start with the
least Square methods and it's the most
common and usually works the best on
most models and we're already looking at
how linear regression works but let's
dig deeper into it and let's take a
closer look how linear regression works
I will provide you with a data set which
has rent area other information in it
looks like our secret agents have put on
their casual wear for this one you need
to predict rent accordingly we are given
area and rent here so you can do linear
regression with more variables but we're
just going to look at the area and then
from that try to figure out what the
rent should be we plot the graph and if
you look at it here you can see that the
graph kind of a linear pattern with a
little dip in it so the area seems the
rent seems to be based on the area in
most of our work as data scientists we
usually try to start with a physical
graph if we can so we can actually look
at it and say hey does what I'm fitting
to this graph look right you can solve a
lot of problems that arise by looking at
the graph and saying no that doesn't
look right at all or oh I should be
looking over here for the this then we
find the mean of area and rent so the
mean just means average and if you take
one two three four five and add them all
together and divide by in this case
there's five areas you get three and the
rent is two four six five and eight if
you add them all together and divide by
five you get five and we plot the mean
on the graph so you can see right here
here's the mean of the rent and the area
it's kind of a very Central Point which
is what we're looking for the average of
everything in there the best fit line
passes through the mean this is real
important when you're eyeballing it as
humans we can do this fairly easy if
it's a straight line through a bunch of
data it gets more complicated
mathematically when you start adding
multiple variables and instead of a line
you have a curve but for basic linear
regression we're going to draw a line
through the data and the line should go
through the means that's going to be
part of the best fit for that line but
we see there are multiple lines that can
pass through the means so depending on
how you look at it you can kind of
Wiggle the line around back and forth so
we keep moving the line to ensure that
the best fit line has the least squared
distance from the data points and this
is you can see right here residual we
have our data point and then we look at
this distance between them and we square
that distance and that's what they mean
by the least squared distance we want
all those distances to add up to the
smallest amount we can we talk about the
distance we call it the residual it
equals the Y actual minus the Y
predicted very straightforward we're
just looking at the distance you can
accidentally switch these and it'll come
out the same because we're going to
square it but when you're working with
other sets of linear regression you want
to make sure you do the Y axial minus
the Y predicted the value of M and C for
the best fit line Y equals MX plus C can
be calculated using the mentioned
formula and you can see here we have m
equals the number of points that's what
n stands for then we have the sigma the
Greek symbol is there which is a
summation of x times y minus the
summation of x times the summation of Y
over the number of the summation of x
squared minus the summation of x squared
of of X all of it squared that can be a
little confusing trying to say that and
then of course your C value is going to
be the summation of Y times the
summation of x squared minus the
summation of x times the summation of x
times y over the total count of the
summation x squared minus the summation
of x squared that's a mouthful normally
we don't worry too much about these
formulas other than to know they're
there now if you're a mathematician you
might go back in there and work on those
and those people who originally started
to put together the different models in
R of course had to know all this math to
build them and had to test it out that's
one of the nice things about R what is
important is that you know about these
formulas so that you know where it's
coming from so if you're using one
linear regression model this is how this
one works there's other linear
regression models based on different
math and so you'd have to be aware when
that math changes and how that changes
the model we find the corresponding
values so in this case if you're going
to break this up and you're building
your own model instead of using the one
in R you would have your rent you would
have your area you would find your rent
squared your area squared and your rent
times area and if we go back one we can
see that that's all the different little
pieces in this model we have x times y
we have x squared we have the sum of X
which is going to be squared we have the
sum of X the sum of Y this is the same
these are all the little pieces in here
that we see for m equals and C equals
and so once we compute all these we have
15 25 55 145 88 very easy to do on a
computer thankfully you could have
millions of these points and it would do
it in a very short period we can then
plug in those values very easily into
this formula and get a final answer and
we'll see that m equals 1.3 and C equals
1.1 and then when we take this for the Y
predicted equals m of i x of I plus C we
can take these and actually run the data
we have so we're going to see how it
predicts so now we find the Y the value
of y predicted so we have our X in and
we want to know what why what we think
white will be based on our formula we
generated the linear regression formula
and so when we come in here we have our
X we have our actual y then we have our
y predict what we think it's going to be
and then we have we take y minus y
predict and we get those values minus
0.4 it's off by 0.3 this one's off by
one this one's on off by minus 1.3 by
0.4 and we go ahead and square that and
then we can sum that square and average
it out and we'll get a value this is
just a summation down here of Y minus y
predicted square is 3.1 and we call that
the least Square value for this line is
3.1 and we go ahead and divide that by
five so when we plot the Y predict and
this is the best fit line and you can
see that it does a pretty good job going
right through the middle of lines and in
something like rent versus area if
you're trying to figure out how much
rent to charge or how many people are
allowed to be in the area that's going
to work but if you're looking for the
rent value compared to the area this
gives you a good idea based on the area
of what you should rent the place for
it's close enough that in the business
world this would work you're not
Computing something down to the
millimeters or micrometers or Nuclear
Physics we're just charging people and
so if you're off by a couple dollars
it's not a big deal you'll be pretty
close to what you think it's worth and
get the right value for your property
use case predicting the revenue using
linear regression now that you have a
good idea of how linear regression works
and we're kicking back on our lounging
sofa today let's work on a real life
scenario where you have to predict the
revenue so we're going to take a data
set and we'll pull this up in just a
minute we'll have a paid organic social
and revenue there are three attributes
we'll be working on the first one is our
paid traffic so all the traffic through
the advertisement that comes in the
non-paid traffic from search engines so
these are people coming to the website
and are doing so because they did a
search for something specific so it's
pulling it from your website all the
traffic coming from social networking
sites so we want to know what's coming
from Twitter and Facebook and and
somehow they've linked into your website
and coming into your marketing area to
buy something and we'll use this to
predict the revenue so we want to know
how all this traffic comes together and
how it's going to affect our cells if
the traffic's coming in we're going to
make use of the multiple linear
regression model so you'll see that this
is very similar to we had before where
we had y equals m times X plus C but
instead we have y equals M1 X1 plus M2
X2 plus m3x3 plus c m is the slope so
you have M1 M2 M3 the three different
slopes of three different lines Y is the
revenue so we're only looking for one
variable and remember this is regression
so we're looking for a number X1 is
going to be the paid traffic and of
course M1 the corresponding slope X2 the
organic traffic and X3 the social
traffic we will follow these steps to
create the regression model we'll start
by generating inputs using the CSV files
we'll then import the libraries
splitting the data into train and test
very important whenever you're doing any
kind of data science applying regression
on paid traffic organic traffic social
traffic so we're going to apply a
regression model on them and then we're
going to validate the model that's the
whole reason we split it to a training
and testing is so we can now validate to
see just how good our model is now
before we open up our I always like to
just take a quick look at the data
itself and we're using the rev.csv file
and this is a CS file or comma separated
variable file we'll just open that with
wordpad any kind of text editor would be
nice to show you what's going on and you
can see we have paid organic social and
revenue across the top so those are
titles for your columns and the values
going down and this is the same as what
we saw on the slide just a minute ago
paid organic social and then revenue
from them they probably have it in more
of a spreadsheet than just a word pad
and I'm using the newer version of our
studio which already has a nice layout
automatically opens up with your console
and terminal window down and left you
have your script and we'll run it in
script and then when I run it line by
line in script you'll see it show up on
the console bottom left I could tape it
straight into the console and it would
do the same thing and then on the right
we have our environment and under the
environment we'll see plots if you're in
an older version the plots will pop up
and you usually are running just in the
console and then you have to open up a
different window to run the script and
you can run the script from there this
opens up everything at the same time
when you use the new R Studio setup and
the first thing we want to do is we want
to go ahead and generate a variable
we'll call it cells and we want to load
this with our data set and so in R we
use the less than minus sign that's the
same as assigned to it's like an arrow
pointing at cells it says whatever it
goes past here is going to be assigned
to cells we want to read in our CSV file
and then I went ahead and fixed the CSV
file up a little bit when I say the CSV
file I mean the path to it
um and we'll go ahead and just paste
that in there and this is my edited
version and you'll see I took wherever
we had the backward slash I switched it
for a forward slash because a backwards
slash is an escape character and
whenever you're programming in just
about any scripting language you want to
do the forward slash instead so like a
good Chef I prep this and copied it into
my clipboard and we can see the full
path here and the full path ends in our
rev.csv files that's the path on my
machine and I'm going to run that and
now we have down here you see it appear
right here oh it must have an error in
my path it says object rev not found let
me fix that real quick and run it again
and this time it does assign the cells
the data set and then we'll just type in
cells and this is the same as printing
it so if you work in other languages
you'll do like print and then sales or
maybe print sales.head if you're in
pandas in python or something like that
but in R you just type in the variable
we'll run this and you can see it
printed out all those columns so that's
the same thing we just looked at and it
says Max print so it emitted 750 rows so
so it has a total of a thousand rows and
we can scroll up here on our console
where the answer came in and if I scroll
up to the top way up to the top there we
go you'll see paid organic social and
revenue so everything looks good on this
and there's a lot of cool things we can
do with it one of the things we can do
is I can summary it so let's do a
summary of cells and we'll run that and
the summary of cells comes in it tells
you your Min first quarter median mean
third quarter Max for paid organic
social breaks it up and you can actually
get kind of a quick view as to what the
data is doing you can take more time to
study this a lot of people look at this
and you can see from the median the mean
that tells you a lot and is divided into
quarters so you have your first quarter
value and your third quarter setup on
there and Max it just gives you a quick
idea what's going on in the data summary
is a really wonderful tool one of the
reasons I like to jump into R before I
might do a major project in something
else or you can run everything enough
and let's take a look at the head head
of cells and let me run this and you can
see it just shows the head of our data
the first six rows in this case and it
starts with one important to know the
other different systems start with zero
and go up R is one that starts with the
first is one and then if we want to do a
plot I'll go ahead and do a plot cells
another really powerful tool that you
can just jump right into with r once you
have your data in here and you'll see
that the plot comes over on the right
hand side and what it does is it
Compares them so if I look at my paid
and my organic and you cross a two
you'll see there's a nice line down the
middle big black line where plus the two
together let me just widen this a little
bit so we can see more of it there we go
same thing with paid and social paid and
revenue so each one of these has a clear
connection to each other so that's a
good sign we have a nice correlation
between the data and you can just
eyeball that that's a good way to jump
in and explore your data rather quickly
and see what's going on so we'll go
ahead and I'll put a pound sign there a
hashtag and splitting the data into
training and test data we want to split
it so that we have something to work
with to train our data set and when we
do our data set you do this with any
data set because you want to make sure
you have a good model and then once
we've trained it we're going to take the
other set of data we pulled off to the
side and we'll test it to see how good
it is if you test it with the training
data that's already got that memorized
and should give you a really good answer
in fact when you get into more advanced
machine learning tools you watch those
very closely you watch your training set
and how it does versus your testing set
and if your training set starts doing
better than your testing set then you're
starting to over train it now that's
more with deep learning and some other
packages that are beyond what we're
working with today but you know this is
important it's very important to
understand that that test and that
training correlate with each other and
gives you an idea what's going on and
make sure that you're set up correctly
and we'll go ahead and set a seed of two
and that's for our random gen generators
so that when we run them you can see
them with just a red there's a ways to
randomize a number you can do like date
and stuff like that but that way we
always use the same random numbers so
we'll seat it with two and then we're
going to need a library in this case
we're going to import the library and we
want to import CA tools and CA tools has
our split function so we're going to be
able to split our data along with many
other tools we're going to need for this
example so they're all built into the ca
tools that's why we need to import that
a lot of times they call them library or
sometimes you hear them referred to as
packages so let's go ahead and run that
line and that brings the library in so
now we can use all those different tools
that are in there and then I'm going to
do a split and we're going to assign to
the split that's going to be our
variable sample split okay so that's one
of the tools we just brought in is to
sample is the actual keyword or the
function word sample.split and we're
going to take our cells and we're going
to go ahead and with split ratio equals
to 0.7 and let's do 0.7 so we make sure
it knows it's a decimal point or float
and what this is saying is that we're
going to take our cells data the
variable we created called cells that
has the data in there and I want to
split it and I'm going to split it so
that 70 percent of it goes in one side
we'll use that for training and 30
percent will go into the other side
which we'll use then for testing out our
model let me go ahead and run that and
let's hold on one second got an error
there spit is definitely very different
than split I don't think we want to spit
our data out we which is actually kind
of what we're doing is spitting it out
but we want to split we want to split
the data something get that spelled
correctly and then when I type in Split
we can just run that because that's now
a variable you'll see that it has true
false false true so it generates a
number of interesting different
statistics going across there as far as
the way it splits the data and right
here if you have not used R in a while
or if you're new to R completely that
line one that's what that little one
means down there and then true false
Falls true that means that's how we're
looking at the data we're splitting all
those different pieces of data in line
one different directions and so we now
want to create our trained set and we're
going to assign that and when we take it
and we assign to the train set a subset
of cells and then the subset of cells is
going to be based on split equal let me
put this in Brackets true so you can see
the values down here is capital T
capital r capital u capital E so I just
want to reflect that on the train and
this is going to take everything where
our split variable is equal to true and
it's going to set cells equal to that
and we'll go ahead and run that and then
we're going to set our test variable as
a subset of cells and if we assign the
true to the train set then we want to
assign the false to our test set so now
we'll have this will have 30 percent of
the variables in it and train will have
70 percent we'll go ahead and run that
so we've now created both our training
set and our test set and we can just
real quickly type in train hit the run
on there and you can see our train set
if we scroll way up to the top I'll have
the column names on there which should
match what we had before paid organic
social and revenue and then we'll type
in test when I hit run on there that's
going to do the same thing it'll spit
out all the test variables going out so
now that we have the test and train
variables we want to go ahead and create
the model and you'll see this in any of
the machine learning tutorials they
always refer to them as models we're
modeling a function of some kind on the
data to fit the data and then we're
going to put the test data through there
to see how well it does and so we're
going to create the variable called
models and I'm going to assign that LM
that is our linear regression model I
love how simplified R makes it just LM
linear regression and then model M I
guess it dates back because the linear
regression model is like one of the
first major models used so they kept it
easy on there and revenue happens to be
the main variable that we want to track
so if you remember correctly from our
formula why is the revenue and then we
have X is our paid traffic X2 organic
traffic and X3 are social traffic so why
is what we want to predict in here and
then you'll see this notation where we
have our squiggle and the period which
means we're going to match up the
revenue lines with the lines of the data
we're putting in here and then I'll put
comma and then our data equals train and
of course that's the training data that
we created so when I hit the Run
remember we did all the discussion about
all those different functions and
formulas to compute our model and how
that's set up when it comes down to it
we spend all our time setting up our
data and then we hit the Run button on
the single line and our model's been
trained so we now have a trained model
here and we can do a summary of the
model summary is such a wonderful
command because you can do that on r
that works on all kinds of different
things on there oops and of course it
does help if I remember that my model
has a capital N when I run it and you'll
see right here tells you a little bit
about the model use a summary on there
comes down here it has our residuals
this is all the information on there as
far as like the minimum the median the
Max has all our coefficients in there if
you remember correctly from our formula
let's just go ahead and switch back over
to that we have M1 X1 M2 X2 M3 X3 plus C
well this right here here's our
intercept and then we have our different
values for each of these so you have our
intercept our paid organic and social
and then it also shows us error and
information on the error and one of the
really nice things about when you're
working with r you can come down here
and you see where we have our Stars down
here and it says three stars really good
two stars maybe one star probably no
correlation and we can see with all of
these it has three stars on them so out
of three stars we get three stars on all
of these there's no four stars four
stars would mean that you have the exact
same data going in as coming out and
then if we're going to do this we want
to actually run a prediction on here and
that's why we saved our test data for so
let's come down here we'll do our
prediction we'll take this variable and
we'll sign it predict model remember the
predict comes from when we imported that
package the ca tools that's all part of
the ca Tools in there so we're going to
predict we're going to use the model and
then we're going to use our test data
pretty straightforward quick and easy
we'll run this and then if we go ahead
and type in the predict it'll print out
what's in that variable and you'll see
down here the predicted values expects
to come out it's going to say our
revenue is and it goes through and it
gives it both the line number and the
actual Revenue value so that's quick and
easy boy we got a prediction really fast
and this is also how you would do it if
you had new data coming in after this
you could predict the revenue based on
these other factors so now that we have
a training model which or we've trained
the data with our training data or we
trained the model with our training data
and we've done a prediction on our model
with our test data we want to look this
up and we took a quick glance from our
training thing our training said it
trained really well but that's not the
final word on it the final word is going
to be comparing it so we want to go
ahead and do comparing predicted versus
actual values what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do a plot and I'm going to
do our test and we're going to do test
Revenue DOT type equals and we can put
this in as a type type 1 or L and then
we have lty equals 1.8 and we're going
to set up for column blue that's a lot
of stuff in there let's go ahead and
just run that so we can see what that
looks like and what that's doing it's
going to generate this nice graph we see
on the right there's our graph you can
see the data comes up and down I'll be
plotting the prediction on there so this
is the values we predicted and then
let's go ahead and do lines and I
actually did this backwards so let me
try that again and we'll start with the
red one we're going to do the first one
in red and I want to start with the
actual test Revenue so here's our test
revenue and we'll go ahead and run this
and so we have a red plot over here in
red go ahead and take a look at that and
pull that over you can see how that
looks goes up and down hard to track
there and then we're going to do a
couple things here we'll plot our test
Revenue
and then we'll make it a little prettier
though it's kind of hard to say see the
way I was crunched up here on the right
as far as size and sizing and everything
but we'll go ahead and have our columns
in blue and run our prediction on there
too you can see they overlap the two
graphs so we have our test revenue and
our prediction and then finally what I
started with is we'll go ahead and plot
the prediction fully on the bottom and
run that and if you look over here on
the graph we put the blue lines over the
red lines and so you'll see a couple
spots where there's red underneath there
but for the most part our prediction is
pretty right on so it looks really tight
looks like a good set of predictions for
what we're working on and this is where
we're looking at the slide right before
we started diving into the r Studio we
can see in the slide here here's a red
this little bit better spread out than
what I have on my screen from AR studio
and the graph shows a predicted Revenue
we see that the two lines are very close
so again they're tight it's right on
this is what we're looking for in our
prediction model but it's not good
enough just having a graph and you
always do both and the reason we do both
is you want to have a visual of it
because sometimes you look at these you
get to the graph you're like oh my gosh
what is that and then sometimes you look
at the graph you go that's right on how
come my accuracy doesn't look right and
you realize that your accuracy might be
off or you're plotting it incorrectly so
let's go ahead and look up the accuracy
and we'll use rmsc that's going to be
the variable name we're going to give it
and sqrt the square root of the mean and
mean just means average and then we want
prediction minus
sales revenue and then we're going to
take this whole thing and we're going to
square it so what we've got here is
we're going to go through let's just
explain this formula we're using is I'm
going to look at the what I predicted
for to be and what the actual sales
what's our prediction versus our sales
comparison to the revenue and when we
compare those two we're going to find
the average and then I'm going or we're
going to square each one of those values
and then we're going to average the
square and then find the square root of
that and that's quite a mouthful the
reason we do it this way the reason we
Square the value and then we find the
means is to generate an answer based on
doesn't matter whether it's plus or
minus there's a lot of other formulas
you can use there to check your accuracy
and all kinds of other things you can do
but a quick straightforward way of doing
is just like this and then let's go
ahead and run this
and then we type in the rmsc and they'll
give us an actual printed value out
let's just see what that looks like and
so we have
866.6338 for our accuracy and so we look
at the
866.63 and we compare that to say 50 000
that's pretty close that's that's
actually a pretty good accuracy given
this model takes a little bit more when
you're playing with accuracies and start
dividing out other different aspects of
it to get something you can communicate
better with but you always start with
the square root means that's always a
good place to start and now you are
thrilled to present our AI bootcamp that
is designed to equip you with the
knowledge and skills you need to thrive
in this fast-paced and ever revolving
field in this six months intensive and
immersive learning experience you will
have the opportunity to dive head first
into the subject matter gaining hands-on
experience and building a strong
foundation in AI we believe in a
practical approach where you will work
on 25 plus Hands-On projects across
various industry verticals providing you
with real world experience what sets a
boot camp apart is a partnership with
Caltech CDMA ensuring academic
excellence and Industry recognition by
successfully completing the boot camp
you will earn a prestigious certificate
and up to 22 CU credits from caldex ctma
validating your expertise in the field
so are you ready to embark on this
transformative Journey are you ready to
unlock the power of AI and take your
career to new heights if so enroll in
our AI boot camp today and become part
of the a revolution the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
what is logistic regression let's say we
have to build a predictive model or a
machine learning model to predict
whether the passengers of the Titanic
ship have survived or not the Shipwreck
so how do we do that so we use logistic
regression to build a model for this how
do we use logistic regression so we have
the information about the passengers
their ID whether they have survived or
not their class and name and so on and
so forth and we use this information
where we already know whether the person
has survived or not that is the labeled
information and we help the system to
train based on this information with
based on this labeled data this is known
as label data and during the process of
building the model we probably will
remove some of the non-essential
parameters or attributes here we only
take those attributes which are really
required to make these predictions and
once we train the model we run new data
through it whereby the model will
predict whether the passenger has
survived or not let's start with what is
supervised learning supervised learning
is one of the two main types of machine
learning methods here we use what is
known as labeled data to help the system
learn this is very similar to how we
human beings learn so let's say you want
to teach a child to recognize an apple
how do we do that we never tell the
child okay this is an apple has a
certain diameter on the top at certain
diameter at the bottom and this has a
certain RGB color no we just show an
apple to the child and tell the child
this is Apple and then next time when we
show an apple child immediately
recognizes yes this is an app supervised
learning works very similar on the
similar lines so where does logistic
regression fit into the overall machine
learning process machine learning is
divided into two types mainly two types
there is a third one called
reinforcement learning but we will not
talk about that right now so one is
supervised learning and the other is
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning uses techniques like clustering
and Association and supervised learning
users techniques like classification and
regression now supervised learning is
used when you have labeled data you have
historical data then you use supervised
learning when you don't have labeled
data then you used unsupervised learning
it's it supervised learning there are
two types of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we are
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it it could be binary
classification like a zero or a one an
example of classification we have just
seen whether the passenger has survived
or not survived like a zero or one that
is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict a value what is known as a
continuous value classification is for
discrete values regression is for a
continuous values let's say you want to
predict a share price or you want to
predict the temperature that will be
there what will be the temperature
tomorrow that is where you use
regression whereas classification are
discrete values is will the customer buy
the product or will not buy the product
will you get a promotion or you will not
get a promotion I hope you're getting
the idea or it could be multi-class
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classification model
would take an image as an input and
classify into multiple classes whether
this image is of a cat or a dog or an
elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes so not necessarily find
reclassification so that is known as
multi-class classification
are going to
form classification because logistic
regression is one of the algorithms used
for classification now the name may be a
little confusing in fact whenever people
come across logistic regression it
always causes confusion because the name
has regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification and in
case you are wondering is there
something similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classifications
so in this video we are going to focus
on supervised learning and within
supervised learning we are going to
focus on classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
various algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about a few addition trees are
quite popular and very easy to
understand and therefore they use for
classification then we have K nearest
neighbors this is another algorithm for
performing classification and then there
is logistic regression and this is what
we are going to focus on in this video
and we are going to go into little bit
of details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as I
mentioned earlier positive regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the X and Y axis X is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and for for the
number of years and when the car broke
down and what was the probability and
that has been plotted along X and Y axis
so this provides an idea or from this
graph we can find about whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between 0 and 1 and as we can
imagine it is intuitive as well as the
number of years are on the Lower Side
maybe one year two years or three years
still after the service the chances of
your car breaking down are very limited
right so for example chances of your car
breaking down on the probability of your
car breaking down within two years of
your last service are 0.1 probability
similarly three years is maybe 0.3 and
so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is a slide here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variables outcome is discrete
so if we are talking about whether the
car is going to break down or not so
that is a discrete value the Y that we
are talking about the dependent variable
that we are talking about what we are
looking at is whether the car is going
to break down or not yes or no that is
what we are talking about so here the
outcome is discrete and not a continuous
way so this is how the logistic
regression curve looks let me explain a
little bit what exactly how exactly we
are going to uh
item in the class like the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say an output
of 0.29 is considered as 0 which means
that the car will not break down so
that's the way logistic regression works
now let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so it can cause
confusion so let's try to remove that
confusion so what is linear regression
linear regression is a process is once
again an algorithm for supervised
learning however here you are going to
find a continuous value you are going to
determine a continuous value it could be
the price of a real estate property it
could be your height how much height
you're going to get or it could be a
stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say at the HR
team of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
us it is straight and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employee's information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be done so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred five
thousand six hundred it is not discrete
like a cat or a dog or an apple or a
banana these are discrete or a yes or a
no these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on this scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
if that is a discrete problem right a
yes or no kind of a problem in this case
we actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label date So based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employee's rating and ratings can be
continuous that is not an issue but the
output is discrete in this case whether
employee got promotion yes no okay so if
we try to plot that and we try to find a
straight line this is how it would look
and as you can see it doesn't look very
right because looks like there will be
lot of errors this root mean square
error if you remember for linear
regression would be very very high and
also the the values cannot go beyond
zero or Beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this clicked
at 0 and 1. but still this straight line
doesn't look right therefore instead of
using a linear equation we need to come
up with something different and
therefore the logistic regression model
looks somewhat like this so we calculate
the probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what the depression is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh at certain rating they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odd so the probability of an
event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus p
this is how you measure the odds now the
values of the odds range from 0 to
Infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes 1 then the value of
the odds is 1 by 0 that will be Infinity
but the probability itself remains
between 0 and 1. now this is how an
equation of a straight line love so Y is
equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x where beta0
is the Y intercept and beta 1 is the
slope of the line if we take the odds
equation and take a log of both sides
then this would look somewhat like this
and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of p x by 1 minus p x
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta 1X which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of PX you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of PX like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 X so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained so let's compare
linear and logistic regression how they
are different from each other let's go
back so linear regression is solved or
used to solve regression problems and
logistic regression is used to solve
classification prompts so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and linear regression
helps to estimate the dependent variable
when there is a change in the
independent variable table whereas here
in case of logistic regression it helps
to calculate the probability or the
possibility of a particular event
happening and linear regression as the
name suggests is a straight line that's
why it's called linear regression
whereas logistic regression is a sigmoid
function and the curve is the shape of
the curve is s it's an s shaped curve
this is another example of application
of logistic regression in weather
prediction that it's going to rain or
not drain now keep in mind both are used
in weather prediction if we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not is
going to be sunny or not it is going to
snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog I hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or a elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
Binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification
Healthcare plastic regression is used to
find the survival rate of a patient so
they take multiple parameters like drama
score a so on and so forth and they try
to predict the rate of survival all
right now finally let's take an example
and see how we can apply logistic
regression to predict the number that is
shown in the image so this is actually a
live demo I will take you into jupyter
notebook and show the code but before
that let me take you through a couple of
slides to explain what we are trying to
do so let's say you have an eight by
eight image and there the image has a
number one two three four and you need
to train your model to predict what this
number is so how do we do this so the
first thing is obviously in any machine
learning process you train your model so
in this case we are using logistic
regression so and then we provide a
training set to train the model and then
we test how accurate our model is with
the test data which means that like any
machine learning process we split our
initial data into two parts training set
and test set with the training set we
train our model and then with the test
set we test the model didn't we get good
accuracy and then we use it for for
inference right so that is typical
methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so I'll not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and then we split
the data into training and test as I
mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and then we build
our model we train our model with the
training set and then we test it with
our test set and find out how accurate
our model is using the confusion Matrix
the heat map and use heat map for
visualizing this and I will show you in
the code what exactly is the confusion
Matrix and how it can be used for
finding the accuracy in our example we
get an accuracy of about 0.94 which is
pretty good or 94 which is pretty good
all right so what is the confusion
Matrix this is an example of a confusion
Matrix and this is used for identifying
the accuracy of a classification model
or like a logistic regression model so
the most important part in a confusion
Matrix is that first of all this as you
can see this is a matrix and the size of
the Matrix depends on how many outputs
we are expecting
so the the most important part here is
that the model will be most accurate
when we have the maximum numbers in its
diagram like in this case that's why it
has almost 93 94 percent because the
diagonals should have the maximum
numbers and the others other than
diagnose the cells other than the
diagonal should have very few numbers so
here that's what is happening so there
is a two here there are there's a one
here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and actual value are the same so
along the diagonals that is true which
means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed are rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100 accuracy everything will be only in
the diagonal there will be no numbers
other than zero in all other cells so
that is like a hundred percent accurate
model okay so that's uh just of how to
use this Matrix how to use this
confusion Matrix I know the name uh is a
little funny sounding confusion Matrix
but actually it is not very confusing
it's very straightforward so you are
just plotting what has been predicted
and what is the labeled information on
what is the actual data that's also
known as the ground truth sometimes okay
these are some fancy terms that are used
so predicted label and the actual name
that's all right okay yeah so we are
showing a little bit more information
here so 38 have been predicted and here
you will see that all of them have been
predicted correctly there have been 38
zeros and
the predicted value and the actual value
is exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has uh there are I think 37
plus 5 yeah 42 have been fed the images
42 images are of Digit three and uh the
accuracy is only 37 of them have been
accurately predicted three of them have
been predicted as number seven and two
of them have been predicted as number
eight and so on and so forth okay all
right so with that let's go into jupyter
notebook and see how the code looks so
this is the code in in Jupiter notebook
for logistic regression in this
particular demo what we are going to do
is train our model to recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
um and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correct a or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then the
last line in this block is to load the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize the
shape of these digits so we can see here
okay if we take a look this is how the
shape is 1797 by 64. these are like
eight by eight images so that's that's
what is reflected in this shape now from
here onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at some of the sample
images that we have loaded so this one
for example creates a figure and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the images this is how the data is
okay and based on this we will actually
train our logistic regression model and
then we will test it and see how well it
is able to recognize so the way it works
is the pixel information so as you can
see here this is an eight by eight pixel
kind of a image and the each pixel
whether it is activated or not activated
that is the information available for
each pixel now based on the pattern of
this activation and non-activation of
the various pixels this will be
identified as a zero for example right
similarly as you can see so overall each
of these numbers actually has a
different pattern of the pixel
activation and that's pretty much that
our model needs to learn for which
number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
okay so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and tests so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times and
then we test it with the test data set
and the split is usually in the form of
and there are various ways in which you
can split this data it is up to the
individual preferences in our case here
we are splitting in the form of 23 and
77 so when we say test size as 20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the data that we
want to split and the the results will
be stored in X underscore train and Y
underscore train for the training data
set and what is X underscore train these
are these are the features right which
is like the independent variable and Y
underscore train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in X underscore train and
since this is a labeled data for each of
them each of the observations we already
have the label information saying
whether this digit is a zero or a one or
a two so that that's this is what will
be used for compare medicine to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way X underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set X underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of this so X
underscore train the shape is
1383 by 64 and Y underscore train has
1383 because there is nothing like the
second part is not required here and
then X underscore test shape we see is
four one four so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression Library
and which is a part of scikit-learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that we
have the logistic regression Library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is uh is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing our data the training data set
and this is our the the predictors and
this is our Target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large and the
training is what takes usually a lot of
time so we spend in machine learning
activities in machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time for the training
part of it okay so here the data set is
relatively small so it was pretty quick
so all right so now our model has been
trained using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for one image
okay I will just try it out with one
image my the first entry in my test data
set and see whether it is correctly
predicting or not so and in order to
test it so for training purpose we use
the fit method there is a method called
fit which is for training the model and
once the training is done if you want to
test for a particular value new input
you use the predict method okay so let's
run the predict method and we pass this
particular image
and we see that the shape is or the
prediction is four so let's try a few
more let me see for the next 10 seems to
be fine so let me just go ahead and test
the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent accurate okay so that's on
this part now what we can also do is we
can also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion Matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well so that we
can also visualize how well this model
has done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and um
we we basically create a confusion
metric an instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion Matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore Matrix method takes
two parameters one is the Y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the Y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion Matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
Matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and the key point out here is
that the accuracy of the model is
determined by how many numbers are there
in the diagonal the more the numbers in
the diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole Matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that so this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value same as
the predictive value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion Matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 Plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion Matrix now let us visualize
this confusion Matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way using a heat map so we
will create a heat map with some We'll
add some colors as well it's uh it's
like a more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map looks and as
you can see here the diagonals again are
all the values are here most of the
values so which means reasonably this
seems to be reasonably accurate and yeah
basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as I
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test value so the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
Matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion Matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well uh the system
has classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of nine so this has also
been predicted correctly nine and actual
value is 9 and this is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images Okay so
let's summarize what we have learned in
this video we discussed about what is
logistic regression and how it fits into
the overall machine learning we
discussed about the different types of
machine learning and how logistic
regression is one of the algorithms for
classification and then we compared
logistic regression with linear
regression because the names may be
sounding similar but these are
completely different algorithms linear
regression is used for predicting
continuous values whereas logistic
regression is used for finding discrete
valence and then we talked about the
math behind logistic regression and we
derive type that function as well the
sigmoid function we did a quick tabular
comparison between linear and logistic
regression we saw some examples of
day-to-day life how logistic regression
is used for some of the class for
solving some of the classification
problems and then in the end we looked
at the code to see how we can Implement
logistic regression to train the model
to identify images there's all kinds of
regression models that come out of this
so we put them aside about side we have
our linear regression which is a
predictive number
used to predict a dependent output
variable based on Independent input
variable
accuracy is a measured using least
squares estimation
so that's where you take it you could
also use absolute value the least
squares is more popular there's reasons
for that mathematically and also for
computer runtime
but it does give you an accuracy based
on the the least Square estimation the
best fit line is a straight line and
clearly that's not always used in all
the regression models there's a lot of
variations on that the output is a
predicted integer value
again this is what we're talking about
we talk about linear regression and
we're talking about regression it means
the numbers coming out linear usually
means we're looking for that line
versus a different model and it's used
in business domain forecasting stocks
it's used as a basis of almost of most
um predictions with numbers so if you're
looking at a lot of numbers you're
probably looking at a linear regression
model
for instance if you do just the high
lows of the stock exchange and you're
going to take a lot more of that if you
want to make money off the stock
you'll find that the linear regression
model fits uh probably better than
almost any of the other models or even
you know high-end neural networks and
all these other different machine
learning and AI models because they're
numbers they're just a straight set of
numbers you have a high value a low
value volume that kind of thing so when
you're looking at something that's
straight numbers and are connected in
that way usually you're talking about a
linear regression model and that's where
you want to start a logistic regression
model used to classify dependent output
variable based on Independent input
variable so just like the linear
regression model unlike all of our
machine learning tools you have your
features coming in and so in this case
you might have a label you know an image
or something like that is probably a
very popular thing right now labeling
broccoli and vegetables or whatever
accuracy is measured using maximum
likelihood estimation the best fit is
given by a curve and we saw that
um
we're talking about linear regression
you definitely are talking about a
straight line although there is other
regression models that don't use
straight lines and usually when you're
looking at a logistic regression the
math as you saw was still kind of a
euclidean line but it's now got that
sigmoid activation which turns it into a
heavily weighted curve and the output is
a binary value between 0 and 1. and it's
used for classification image processing
as I mentioned is is what people usually
think of
although they use it for classification
of
like a window of things so you could
take a window of stock history and you
could clap generate classifications
based on that and separate the data that
way if it's going to be that this
particular pattern occurs is going to be
upward trending or downward trending
in fact a number of stock
Traders use that not to tell them how
much to bid or what to bid but they use
it as to whether it's worth looking at
the stock or not whether the Stock's
going to go down or go up and it's just
a zero one do I care do I even want to
look at it so let's do a demo so you can
get a picture of what this looks like in
Python code let's predict the price at
which insurance should be sold to a
particular customer based on their
medical history
we will also classify on a mushroom data
set to find the poisonous and
non-poisonous mushrooms
and when you look at these two datas the
first one we're looking at the price so
the price is a number so let's predict
the price which the insurance should be
sold to and the second one is we're
looking at either as poisonous or it's
not poisonous so first off before we
begin the demo I'm in the Anaconda
Navigator
in this one I've loaded the python 3.6
and using the Jupiter notebook and you
can use jupyter notebook by itself you
can use the Jupiter lab which allows
multiple tabs it's basically the
notebook with tabs on it
but the Jupiter notebook is just fine
and it'll go into Google Chrome which is
what I'm using for my Internet Explorer
and from here we open up new and you'll
see python3 and again this is loaded
with python 3.6 and we're doing the
linear versus logic regression or logit
you'll see l-o-g-i-t
um is one of the one of the names that
kind of pops up when you do a search on
here but it is a logic we're looking at
the logistic regression models
and we'll start with the linear
regression because it's easy to
understand you draw a line through stuff
and so in programming we got a lot of
stuff to unfold here in our in our
startup as we preload all of our
different parts
let's go ahead and break this up we have
at the beginning import pandas
so this is our data frame uh it's just a
way of storing the data think of a you
talk about a data frame think of a
spreadsheet a rows and columns it's a
nice way of viewing the data
and then we have we're going to be
bringing in our pre-processing labeling
coder I'll show you what that is when we
get down to it it's easier to see in the
data but there's some data in here like
sex it's male or female so it's not like
an actual number it's a easier one or
the other that kind of stuff ends up
being encoded that's what this label
encoder is right here
we have our test split model
if you're going to build a model you do
not want to use all the data you want to
use some of the data and then test it to
see how good it is and if it can't have
seen the data you're testing on until
you're ready to test it on there and see
how good it is
and then we have our logistic regression
model our categorical one and then we
have our linear regression model these
are the two these right here let me just
um
clear all that there we go these two
right here are what this is all about
logistic versus uh linear is it
categorical are we looking for a true
false or are we looking for a specific
number
and then finally usually at the very end
we have to take and just ask how
accurate is our model did it work if
you're trying to predict something in
this case we're going to be doing
um
Insurance costs how close to the
insurance cost does it measure that we
expect it to be you know if you're an
insurance company you don't want to
promise to pay everybody's medical bill
and not be able to
and in the case of the mushrooms you
probably want to know just how much at
risk you are for following this model uh
as far as whether you're going to get a
poisonous mushroom and die or not
um so we'll look at both of those and
we'll get talk a little bit more about
the shortcomings and the value of these
different processes so let's go ahead
and run this this is loaded the data set
on here and then because we're in
jupyter Notebook I don't have to put the
print on there we just do data set and
by and it prints out all the different
data on here and you can see here for
our insurance because we're starting
with we're loading that with our pandas
and it prints it in a nice format where
you can see the age sex body mass index
number of children smoker so this might
be something that the insurance company
gets from the doctor it says hey we're
gonna this is what we need to know
to give you a quote for what we're going
to charge you for your insurance
and you can see that it has 1 338 rows
and seven columns you can count the
columns one two three four five six
seven so there's seven columns on here
and the column we're really interested
in is charges I want to know what the
charges are going to be what can I
expect
not a very good Arrow drawn
um
what to expect them to charge on there
so is this going to be you know is this
person going to cost me uh 16 884
dollars or is this person only going to
cost me uh
3866. how do we guess that so that we
can guess what the minimal charge is for
their insurance
the thing you really need to notice on
this data and I mentioned it before but
I'm going to mention it again because
pre-processing data is so much of the
work in data science
um sex well how do you how do you deal
with female versus male are you a smoker
yes or no what does that mean
region how do you look at regions not a
number how do you draw a line between
Southwest and Northwest
um you know they're objects it's either
your Southwest or your Northwest just
not like I'm southwest I guess you could
do longitude and latitude but the data
doesn't come in like that it comes in as
true false or whatever you know it's
either your Southwest or your Northwest
so we need to do a little bit of
pre-processing of the data on here to
make this work
oops there we go okay so let's take a
look and see what we're doing with
pre-processing
and again this is really where you spend
a lot of time with data science is
trying to understand how and why you
need to do that and so we're going to do
you'll see right up here
label uh and then we're going to do the
do a label encoder one of the modules we
brought in so this is sklearns label
encoder
I like the fact that it's all pretty
much automated but if you're doing a lot
of work with label encoder you should
start to understand how that fits
and then we have uh label dot fit
right here where we're going to go ahead
and do the data set dot sex dot drop
duplicates and then for data set sex
we're going to do the label transform
the data set sex and so we're looking
right here at male or female
and so it usually just converts it to a
zero one because there's only two
choices on here
same thing with the smoker it's zero or
one so we're going to transfer the
transa change the smoker 0 1 on this
and then finally we did region down here
region does it a little bit different
we'll take a look at that and it it's I
think in this case it's probably going
to do it because we did it on this label
transform
with this particular setup it gives each
region a number like 0 1 2 3. so let's
go ahead and take a look and see what
that looks like go and run this
and you can see that our new data set
has age that's still a number six is
zero or one so zero is female one is
male
number of children we left that alone uh
smoker one or zero says no or yes on
there we actually just do one for no
zero or no yeah one for no I'm not sure
how it organized them but it turns the
smoker into zero or one yes or no
and then region it did this as 0 1 2 3
so it's three regions
now a lot of times in in when you're
working with data science and you're
dealing with regions or even word
analysis
um instead of doing one column and
labeling it zero one two three a lot of
times you increase your features and so
you would have region Northwest would be
one column yes or no region Southwest
would be one column yes or no true zero
one but for this this particular setup
this will work just fine on here now we
spent all that time getting it set up uh
here's the fun part here's the part
where we're actually using our setup on
this and you'll see right here we have
our
why linear regression data set drop the
charges because that's what we want to
predict
and so our X I'm sorry our X linear data
set drop the charges because that's what
we're going to predict we're predicting
charges right here so we don't want that
as our input for our features
and our y output is charges that's what
we want to guess we want to guess what
the charges are
and then what we talked about earlier is
we don't want to do all the data at once
so we're going to take
0.3 means 30 percent we're going to take
30 percent of our data and it's going to
be as the trade as the testing site so
here's our y test and our X test down
there
um and so that part our model will never
see it until we're ready to test to see
how good it is and then of course right
here you'll see our training set and
this is what we're going to train it
we're going to trade it on 70 of the
data
and then finally the big ones this is
where all the magic happens this is
where we're going to create our magic
setup and that is right here our linear
model we're going to set it equal to the
linear regression model
and then we're going to fit the data on
here
and then at this point I always like to
pull up
um if you if you if you're working with
a new models good to see where it comes
from and this comes from the site kit
learn
and this is the sklearn linear model
linear regression that we imported
earlier
and you can see they have different
parameters the basic parameter works
great if you're dealing with just
numbers I mentioned that earlier with
stock high lows this model will do as
good as any other model out there for do
if you're doing just the very basic high
lows and looking for linear fit a
regression model fit
um and which one of the things
when I'm looking at this as I look for
methods
and you'll see here's our fit that we're
using right now and here's our predict
and we'll actually do a little bit in
the middle here as far as looking at
some of the parameters hidden behind it
the math that we talked about earlier
and so we go in this we go ahead and run
this
you'll see it loads a linear regression
model and just has a nice output that
says hey I loaded the linear regression
model
and then the second part is we did the
fit and so this model is now trained our
linear model is now trained on the
training data
and so one of the things we can look at
is the for idx and call a name and
enumerate X linear train columns
kind of an interesting thing this prints
out the coefficients so when you're
looking at the back end of the data you
remember we had that formula BX X1 plus
bxx2 plus the inner plus the intercept
and so forth these are the actual
coefficients that are in here this is
what it's actually multiplying these
numbers by
and you can see like region gets a minus
value so when it heads it up I guess a
region you can read a lot into these
numbers uh it gets very complicated
there's ways to mess with them if you're
doing a basic linear regression model I
usually don't look at them too closely
but you might start looking in these and
saying hey you know what uh smoker look
how smoker impacts the cost
it's just massive so this is a flag that
hey the value of the smoker really
affects this model
and then you can see here where the body
mass index so somebody who is overweight
is probably less healthy and more likely
to have cost money and then of course
age is a factor and then you can see
down here we have the sexist in a factor
also and it just it changes as you go in
there negative number it probably has
its own meaning on there
again it gets really complicated when
you dig into the workings and how the
linear model works on that and so we can
also look at the intercept this is just
kind of fun so it starts at this
negative number and then adds all these
numbers to it that's all that means
that's our intercept on there and that
fits the data we have on that
and so you can see right here we can go
back and
oops give me just a second there we go
we can go ahead and predict the unknown
data and we can print that out
and if you're going to create a model to
predict something we'll go ahead and
predict it here's our y prediction value
linear model predict
and then we'll go ahead and create a new
data frame
in this case from our X linear test
group
we'll go ahead and put the cost back
into this data frame and then the
predicted cost we're going to make that
equal to our y prediction
and so when we pull this up you can see
here that we have the actual cost and
what we predicted the cost is going to
be
there's a lot of ways to measure the
accuracy on there but we're going to go
ahead and jump into our mushroom data
which
and so in this you can see here we've
run our basic model we built our
coefficients you can see the intercept
the back end you can see how we're
generating a number here
now with mushrooms we want a yes or no
we want to know whether we can eat them
or not
and so here's our mushroom file we're
going to run this take a look at the
data and again you can ask for a copy of
this file send a note over to
simplylearn.com
and you can see here that we have a
class the cap shape cap surface and so
forth so there's a lot of feature in
fact there's 23 different columns in
here going across
and when you look at this I'm not even
sure what these particular like p e e p
e I don't even know what the class is on
this
I'm going to guess by the notes that the
class is poisonous or edible
so if you remember before we had to do a
little pre-coding on our data same thing
with here
we have our cap shape which is b or X or
k
we have cap color these really aren't
numbers so it's really hard to do
anything with just a a single number so
we need to go ahead and turn those into
a label encoder which again there's a
lot of different encoders with this
particular label encoder it's just
switching it to 0 1 2 3 and giving it an
integer value
in fact if you look at all the columns
all of our columns are labels and so
we're just going to go ahead and loop
through all the columns in the data and
we're going to transform it into a label
encoder and so when we run this you can
see how this gets shifted from
xbxxk to zero one two three four five or
whatever it is class is 0 1 1 being
poisonous zero looks like it's editable
and so forth on here so we're just
encoding it if you were doing this
project depending on the results you
might encode it differently like I
mentioned earlier you might actually
increase the number of features as
opposed to laboring 0 1 2 3 4 5. in this
particular example it's not going to
make that big of a difference how we
encode it
and then of course we're looking for the
class whether it's poisonous or edible
so we're going to drop the class in our
X Logistics model and we're going to
create our y Logistics model is based on
that class so here's our x y
and just like we did before we're going
to go ahead and split it
using 30 percent for test
70 percent to program the model on here
and that's right here whoops there we go
there's our train and test
and then you'll see here on this next
setup
this is where we create our model all
the magic happens right here
we go ahead and
create a logistics model I have up the
max iterations if you don't
change this for this particular problem
you'll get a warning that says this has
not converged
because that that's what it does is it
goes through the math and it goes hey
can we minimize the error and it keeps
finding a lower and lower error and it
still is changing that number so that
means it hasn't conversed yet it hasn't
find the lowest amount of error it can
and the default is 100. there's a lot of
settings in here so when we go in here
to let me pull that up from the sklearn
so we pull that up from the SK learn
model
you can see here we have our logistic it
has our different settings on here that
you can mess with most of these work
pretty solid on this particular setup so
you don't usually mess a lot usually I
find myself adjusting the iteration and
I'll get that warning and then increase
the iteration on there and just like the
other model you can go just like you did
with the other model we can scroll down
here and look for our methods
and you can see there's a lot of methods
available on here and certainly there's
a lot of different things you can do
with it
but the most basic thing we do is we fit
our model make sure it's set right and
then we actually predict something with
it so those are the two main things
we're going to be looking at on this
model is fitting and predicting there's
a lot of cool things you can do that are
more advanced but for the most part
these are the two which I use when I'm
going into one of these models and
setting them up
so let's go ahead and close out of our
sklearn setup on there
and we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see here it's now loaded
this up there we now have a
logistic model and we've gone ahead and
done a predict here also just like I was
showing you earlier
so here's where we're actually
predicting the data so we we've done our
first two lines of code as we create the
model we fit the model to our training
data and then we go ahead and predict
for our test data now in the previous
model we didn't dive into the test score
I think I just showed you a graph and we
can go in there and there's a lot of
tools to do this we're going to look at
the model score on this one let me let
me just go ahead and run the model score
and it says that it's pretty accurate
we're getting a roughly 95 percent
accuracy wow that's good one 95 accuracy
95 accuracy might be good for a lot of
things
but when you look at something as far as
whether you're going to pick a mushroom
on the side of the trail and eat it we
might want to look at the confusion
Matrix and for that we're going to put
in our y logistic test the actual values
of edible and unedible and we're going
to put in our prediction value
and if you remember on here let's see I
believe it's poisonous was one zero is
edible
so let's go ahead and run that 0 1 0 is
good so here is a confusion Matrix and
this is if you're not familiar with
these we have true true true false
true false false false
so it says out of the edible mushrooms
we correctly labeled 1201 mushrooms
edible that were edible
and we correctly measured
1113 poisonous mushrooms as poisonous
but here's the kicker
I labeled
56 edible mushrooms as being
poisonous well that's not too big of a
deal we just don't eat them
but I measured 68 mushrooms as being
edible that were poisonous
so probably not the best choice to use
this model to predict whether you're
going to eat a mushroom or not
and you'd want to dig a Little Deeper
before you start picking mushrooms off
the side of the trail so a little
warning there when you're looking at any
of these data models looking at the
error and how that error fits in with
what domain you're in domain in this
case being edible mushrooms
be a little careful make sure that
you're looking at them correctly
so we've looked at uh edible or not
edible we've looked at a regression
model as far as the N values what's
going to be the cost and what our
predicted cost is so we can start
figuring out how much to charge these
people for their insurance
and so these really are the fundamentals
of data science when you pull them
together when I say data science to talk
about your machine learning code
and hopefully you got a little
classification is probably one of the
most widely used tools in machine
learning in today's world and is also
one of the simpler versions to start
understanding how a lot of machine
Learning Works we're going to start by
taking a look at what exactly is
classification the important
terminologies around classification
we'll look at some real world
applications my favorite popular
classification algorithms and there are
a lot out there so we're only going to
touch briefly on a variety of them so
you can see how they the different
flavors work and we'll have some
Hands-On Demos in Python embedded
throughout the tutorial classification
classification is a task that requires
the use of machine learning algorithms
to learn how to assign a class label to
a given data you can see in this diagram
we have our unclassified data it goes
through a classification algorithms and
then you have classified data it's hard
to just see it as data and that really
is where you kind of start and where you
end when you start running these machine
learning algorithms and classification
and the classification algorithms is a
little black box in a lot of respects
and we'll look into that you can see
what I'm talking about when we start
swapping in and out different models
let's say we are given the task of
classifying a given bunch of fruits and
vegetables on the basis of their
category I.E fruits are to be grouped
together and vegetables are to be
grouped together and so we have a data
set we'll call it the bunch is divided
into clusters one of which consists of
the fruits while the other has the
vegetables you can actually look at this
as any kind of data when we talk about
breast cancer can we sort out an images
to see what is malignant what is B9 very
popular one can you classify flowers the
iris data set certainly in Wildlife can
you classify different animals and track
where they're going classification is
really the bottom starting point or the
Baseline for a lot of machine learning
and setting it up and trying to figure
out how we're going to break the data up
so we can use it in a way that is
beneficial so here the fruits and the
vegetables are grouped into clusters and
each clusters has a specific
characteristic I.E whether they are a
fruit or a vegetable and you can see we
have a pile of fruits and vegetables we
feed it into the algorithm and the
algorithm separates them out and you
have fruits and vegetables so some
important terminologies before we dig
into how it sorts them out and what that
all means we look at the terminologies
you have a classifier that's the
algorithm that is used to map the input
data to a specific category the
classification model the model that
predicts or draws a class to the input
data given for training feature it is an
individual measurable property of the
phenomena being observed and labels the
characteristics on which the data points
of a data set are categorized the
classifier and the classification model
go together a lot of times the class a
fire is part of the classification model
and then you choose which classifier you
use after you choose which model you're
using where features are what goes in
labels are what comes out so your
classifier model is right in the middle
of that that's that little black box we
were just talking about clusters they
are a group of data points which have
some common characteristics binary
classification it is a classification
condition with two outcomes which are
either true or false multi-label
classification this is a classification
condition where each sample is assigned
to a set of labels or targets
multi-class classification the
classification with more than two
classes here each sample is assigned to
one and only one label when we look at
this group of terminologies a few
important things to notice going from
the top clusters when we cluster data
together we don't necessarily have to
have an end goal we just want to know
what what features cluster together
these features then are mapped to the
outcome we want in many cases the first
step might not even care about the
outcome only about what data connects
with other data and there's a lot of
clustering algorithms out there that do
just the clustering part binary
classification it is a classification
condition with two outcomes which are
either true or false we're talking
usually it's a it's either a cat or it's
not a cat it's either a dog or it's not
a dog that's the kind of thing we talk
about binary classification and then
that goes into
multi-label classification think of
label as you can have an object that is
brown you can have an object that is
labeled as a dog so it has a number of
different labels that's very different
than a multi-class classification where
each one's a binary you can either be a
cat or a dog you can't be both a cat and
a dog real world applications so to make
sense of of this of course the challenge
is always in the details is to
understand how we apply this in the real
world so in real world applications we
use this all the time we have email spam
classifier so you have your email inbox
coming in it goes through the email
filter that we usually don't see in the
background and it goes this is either
valid email or it's a Spam and it puts
it in the spam filter if that's what it
thinks it is Alexa's voice classifier
Google Voice any of the voice
classifiers they're looking for points
so they try to group words together and
then they try to find those groups so
words trigger a Class A classifier so it
might be that the classifier is to open
your tasks program or open your text
program so she can start sending a text
sentimental sentiment analysis is really
big when we're tracking products we're
tracking marketing trying to understand
whether something is liked or disliked
is huge that's like one of the biggest
driving forces in sales nowadays and you
almost have to have these different
filter is going on if you're running a
large business of any kind fraud
detection you can think of banks they
find different things on your bank
statement and they detect that there's
something going on there they have
algorithms for tracking the logs on
computers they start finding weird logs
on computers they might find a hacker I
mentioned cat and dog so here's our
image classification we have a neighbor
who runs an outdoor webcam and we like
to have it come up with a classification
when the wild animals in our area are
out like foxes we actually have a
mountain lion that lives in the area so
it's nice to know when he's here
handwriting prediction classifying A B C
D and then classifying words to go with
that so let's go ahead and roll our
sleeves up and take a look at some
popular classification algorithms before
we look at the algorithms let's go back
and take a look at our definitions we
have a classifier and a classification
model so we're looking at the classifier
an algorithm that is used to map the
input data to a specific category one of
those algorithms is a logistic
regression the logistic regression is
the classification algorithm used to
model the probability of a certain class
or event existing such as pass fail or
win lose Etc it provides its output
using the logistic function or sigmoid
function to return the probability value
that can then be mapped to two or more
discrete classes a sigmoid function is
an activation function that fits the
variable and limit the output to a range
between 0 and 1. a standard sigmoid
function or logistic function is
represented by the formula FX equals 1
over 1 plus e to the minus X where X is
the equation of the line and E is the
exponential and just taking a quick look
at this you can think of this as being a
point of uncertainty and so as we get
closer and closer to the middle of the
line it's either activated or not and we
want to make that just shoot way up so
so you'll see a lot of the activation
formulas kind of have this nice S curve
where it approaches one and approaches
zero and based on that there's only a
small region of error and so you can see
in the sigmoid logistic function the one
over one plus e minus x to the minus X
you can see in frames that that nice S
curve we also can use a tangent
variation there's a lot of other
different models here as far as the
actual algorithm this is the most
commonly used one let's go ahead and
roll up our sleeves and take a look at a
demo that is going to use a logistic
regression so we're going to have the
activation formula and the model because
you have to have you have to have both
for this we will go into our Jupiter
notebook now I personally use the
Anaconda navigator to open up the
Jupiter notebook to set up my IDE as a
web-based it's got some advantages that
it's very easy to display in but it also
has some disadvantages in that if you're
trying to do multi-threads and multiply
processing you start running into single
get issues with python and then I jump
to pycharm really depends on whatever ID
you want just make sure you've installed
numpy and the sklearn modules into your
python in whatever environment you're
working in so that you'll have access to
that for this demo now the team in the
back has prepared my code for me which
I'll start bringing in one section at a
time so we can go through it before we
do that it's always nice to actually see
where this information is coming from
and what we're working with so the first
part is we're going to import our
packages which you need to install into
your Python and that's going to be your
numpy we usually use numpy as in p and
then from SK learn the learn model we're
going to use a logistic regression and
from sklearnmetrics we're going to
import the classification report
confusion Matrix and if we go ahead and
open up S the site kit-learn.org and go
under their API you can see all the
different features and models they have
and we're looking at the linear model
logistic regression one of the more
common classifiers out there and if we
go ahead and go into that and dig a
Little Deeper you'll see here where they
have the different settings it even says
right here note the regularization is
applied by default so by default that is
the activation formula being used now
we're not going to spend we might come
back to this look at some of the other
models because it's always good to see
what you're working with but let's go
ahead and jump back in here and we have
our Imports we're going to go ahead and
run those so these are now available to
us as we go through our Jupiter notebook
script and they put together a little
piece of data for us this is simply
going through zero to one actually let's
go ahead and print this out over here
we'll go ahead and print X just so you
can see we're actually looking for and
when we run this you can see that we
have our X 0 1 2 through 9 we reshaped
it the reason for this is just looking
for a row of data usually we have
multiple features we just have the one
feature which happens to be zero through
nine and then we have our 10 answers
right down here 0 1 0 0 1 1 1 1. you can
bring in a lot of different data
depending on what you're working with
you can make your own you can instead of
having this as just a single you could
actually have like multiple features in
here but we just have the one feature
for this particular demo and this is
really where all the magic happens right
here and I told you it's like a black
box that's the part that is is kind of
hard to follow and so if you look right
here we have our model we talked about
the model right there and then we went
ahead and set it for Library linear as I
showed you earlier that's actually
default so it's not that important
random State equals zero this stuff you
don't worry too much about and then with
the site kit learn you'll see the model
fit this is very common into site kit
they use similar stuff in a lot of other
different packages but you'll you'll see
that that's very common you have to fit
your data and that means we're just
taking the data and we're fitting our X
right here which is our features that's
our X and here's why these are the
labels we're looking for so before we
were looking at is it fraud is it not is
it cat is it not that kind of thing and
this is looking at 0 1 so we want to
have a binary set up on this and we'll
go ahead and run this you can see right
here it just tells us what we loaded it
with as our defaults and this model has
now been created and we've now fit our
data to it and then comes the fun part
you work really hard to clean your data
to bake it and cook it there's all kinds
of I don't know why they go with the
cooking terms as far as how we get this
data formatted then you go through and
you pick your model you pick your solver
and you have to test it to see hey which
one's going to be best and so we want to
go ahead and evaluate the model and you
do this is that once you've figured out
which one is going to work the best for
you you want to evaluate it so you can
compare it to your last Model and you
can either update it to create a new one
or maybe change the solver to something
else I mentioned tangent and that's one
of the other common ones that's commonly
used with language for some reason the
tangent even though it looks almost to
me identical to the one we're using with
the sigmoid function if for some reason
it activates better with language even
though it's a very small shift in the
actual math behind it we already looked
at the data early but we'll go and look
at it again just you can see we look at
we have our rows of 0 1 row it only has
one entity and we have our output that
matches these rows and these do have to
match you'll get an error if you put in
something with a different shape so if
you have 10 rows of data and nine
answers it's going to give you an error
because you need to have 10 answers for
it a lot of times you separate this too
when you're doing larger models but for
this we're just going to take a quick
look at that the first thing we want to
start looking that is The Intercept one
of the features inside our linear
regression model we'll go ahead and run
that and print it you'll see here we
have an intercept of minus
1.516 and if we're going to look at The
Intercept we should also look at our
coefficients and if you run that you'll
see that we get a list we get the our
coefficient is the 0.7035 you can just
think of this as your euclidean geometry
for very basic model like this where it
intercepts the Y at some point and we
have a coefficient multiplying by it a
little more complicated in the back end
but that is the just this simple model
which is the one feature in there and
we'll go ahead and reprint the Y because
I want to put them on top of each other
with the Y predict and so these were the
Y values we put in and this is the Y
predict we had coming out and you can
see here we go there's the Y actual and
there's what the prediction comes in now
keep in mind that we used the ACT actual
complete data as part of our training
that is if you're doing a real model a
big stopper right there because you
can't really see how good it did unless
you split some data off to test it on
this is the first step is you want to
see how your model actually tests on the
data you trained it with and you can see
here there is this point right here
where it has it wrong and this point
right here where it also has it wrong
and it makes sense because we're going
our input is 0 1 0 through 9 and it has
to break it somewhere and this is where
the break is so it says this half the
data is going to be zero because that's
what it looked like to me if I was
looking at it without an algorithm and
this data is probably going to be one
and I I didn't I forgot to point this
out so let's go back up here I just kind
of glanced over this window here where
we did a lot of stuff let's go back and
just take a look at that what was done
here is we ran a prediction so this is
where our predict comes in is our
model.predict so we had a model fit we
created the model we programmed it to
give us the right answer now we go ahead
and predict what we think it's going to
be there's our model that predict
probability of X and then we have our y
predict which is very similar but this
has to do more with the probability
numbers so if you remember down below we
had the setup where we're looking at
that sigmoid function that's what this
is returning and the Y predict is
returning a 0 or a one and then we have
our confusion Matrix we'll look at that
and we have our report which just
basically Compares our y to our y
predict which we just did it's kind of
nice a simple data so it's really easy
to see what we're doing that's why we do
use the simple data this can get really
complicated when you have a lot of
different features and things going on
in splits so here we go we've had our I
printed out our actual and our
prediction so this is the actual data
this is what the predict ran and then
we'll go ahead and do we're going to
print out the confusion Matrix we were
just talking about that this is great if
you have a lot of data to look at but
you can see right here a confusion
Matrix says if you remember from the
confusion Matrix we have the two this is
two correct one two and uh it's been a
while since I looked at a confusion
Matrix there's the two and then we have
this one which is our six that's where
the six comes from and then we have this
one which is the one false this is the
two one so we have this one here and
this one here which is misclassified
this really depends on what data you're
working with as to what your is
important you might be looking at this
model and if this model this confusion
Matrix comes up and says that you
misclassified even one person as being
non-malignant cancer that's a bad model
I wouldn't want that classification I'd
want this number to be zero I wouldn't
care if this false positive was off by a
little bit more long as I knew that I
was correct on the important factor that
I don't have cancer so you can see that
this confusion Matrix really aims you in
the right direction of what you need to
change in your model how you need to
adjust it and then there's of course a
report reports are always nice if you
notice we generated a report earlier
we'll go and just print the report up
and you can remember this is a report
it's a classification report y comma y
predict so we're just putting in our two
values basically what we did here
visually with our actual and our
predicted value and we'll go ahead and
run the report and you you can see it
has the Precision the recall your F1
score your support translated into a
accuracy macro average and weighted
average so it has all the numbers a lot
of times when working with clients or
with the shareholders in the company
this is really where you start because
it has a lot of data and they can just
kind of stare at it and try to figure it
out and then you start bringing in like
the confusion Matrix I almost do this in
Reverse as to what this show I would
never show your shareholders The
Intercept of the coefficient that's for
your internal team only working on
machine language but the confusion
Matrix and the report are very important
those are the two things you really want
to be able to show on these and you can
see here we did a decent job of
classifying the data managed to get a
significant portion of it correct we had
or was it accuracy here is a 0.80 F1
score that kind of thing so you know
it's a pretty accurate model of course
this is pretty goofy because it's very
simple model and it's just splitting the
model between ones and zeros so that was
our demo of the on logistic regression
on there let's go and take a look at K
nearest neighbors uh this one is another
very highly used and important algorithm
to understand K nearest neighbors is a
simple algorithm which stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on the similarity measure the K
nearest neighbor finds out the class of
the new data point by finding its
nearest neighbors if there are three
data points of Class A and two data
points of Class B near to the new data
point then the k n classifies the new
data point as Class A the K and K
nearest neighbors is the number of
nearest neighbors we are looking for I
hear I.E if we say k equals three this
means that we are looking for nearest
three neighbors of unclassified data
point usually we take the K value
between 3 to 10 as it leads to a better
result a smaller value of K means that
noise will have a bigger influence on
the result and a larger value of K makes
it computationally expensive hence the
data scientists before the range of K
between 3 and 10. when we talk about
noise remember the data we just looked
at was zero one one zero zero it had
some some values were cut it and set
everything to the right is a one
everything to the left is a zero but I
had some ones and zeros mixed in there
that's called noise that's what they're
talking about is there's some things
that are right in the middle in the
classification which makes it very hard
to classify so suppose we're trying to
find the class for a new Point indicated
by the red color and you can see it's
kind of right between the cat right
between the dogs let k equal three so we
are finding the 3nn for the red data
point by looking at the plot on the
right we can see that the red data point
belongs to the class dogs as it has two
votes for class dog and one vote for
class cat and if you ask the question
well what are you measuring the distance
what is that distance it could be the
measurements of the ears whether they're
pointed or floppy that might be one of
the features you're looking at is how
floppy the ears are another one might be
the whiskers versus the nose and then
you take those measurements and using
the one of the most common things in K
means measurement is the euclidean
geometry you can figure out the distance
between those points there's a lot of
different algorithms for that but you
can think about it that you do have to
have some kind of solid data to measure
and so we can conclude that the new data
point belongs to the class dog so let's
go ahead and see what this looks like in
code and do a demo on the K nearest
Neighbors in here and we'll go right
back into our Jupiter notebook and open
up a new Python Programming script page
of course once we're in here we'll want
to look at the site kit learn I did just
a quick search for us K neighbors KN
neighbors classifier this actually is
the older version 0.0 no 1.023 is the
one we want and you'll see here that we
have all their defaults in Neighbors
equals five it defaults we were talking
about that between three and ten there's
different ways to weigh it there's an
algorithm based on it I mentioned
euclidean geometry finding the distance
there's other algorithms for figuring
out what that distance is and how to
weight those and there's a lot of other
parameters you can adjust for the most
part the K means uh basic setup is a
good place to start and just let the
defaults go we might play with some of
those we'll see what the guys in the
back did and from here we're going to
import numpy we're going to use pandas
if you haven't been running pandas
pandas is our data frame which sits on
top of numpy's data frames are you know
numpy's is our number array pandas is
our data frame matplot library because
we're going to plot some graphs
everybody likes some pretty pictures it
makes it a lot easier to see what's
going on when you have a nice display
and that's also what the Seaborn is in
here in the setup that sits on top of
the matplot library the ones we really
want to look at right here are the what
we're bringing in from sklearn these
ones right here so from sklearn we're
going to load I mentioned the breast
cancer that's a very popular one because
it has I believe it's 36 measurements so
there's 36 features and unless you're a
expert you're not going to know what any
of those features really mean you can
sort of guess but their special
measurements they take of when they take
a image and of course our confusion
Matrix so that we can take a look and
see what the data looks like and how
good we did and then we have our KN at
Neighbors classifier on here and then I
mentioned that whenever you do training
and testing you want to split the data
up you don't want to train the data and
then test it on the same data that just
tells you how good your training model
is it doesn't tell you whether it
actually works on unknown data and so
this just splits it off so that we can
train it and then we can take a look at
data we don't have in there and see how
good it did and we'll go ahead and load
our data up so here's our our setup on
that oops there we go so we're going to
go ahead and load the data up we have
our x value and that's going to come
from our breast cancer.data and column
breast cancer feature names so there's
our actual all our different features
we'll print that out here in a second
and then we have our mean area mean
compactness so I guess we're going to
take the data and we're only going to
use a couple of the columns this just
makes it easier to read of course when
you actually we're going to do this
you'd want to use all your columns and
then we have our Y and this is simply
whether it's either malignant or B9 and
then we want to go ahead and drop the
first line because that's how it came in
on there and we'll go ahead okay let's
just take a look at this a little closer
here let's go and run this real quick
and just because I like to see my data
before I run it we can look at this and
we can look at the original features
remember we're only going to use two
features off of here just to make it a
little easier to follow and here's the
actual data and you can see that this is
just this massive stream of data coming
in here it's going to just skip around
because there's so much in there to set
up I think there's like 500 if I
remember correctly and you can see
here's all the different measurements
they take but we don't we don't really
need to see that on here we're just
going to take a look at just the two
columns and then also our solution we'll
go ahead and just do a Quick Print y on
here so you can see what the Y looks
like and it is simply just zero zero
zero you know
b90001 so a one means it's B9 0 means
it's malignant that's what we're looking
at on that go and cut that out of there
the next stage is to go ahead and split
our data I mentioned that earlier we'll
just go ahead and let them do the
splitting forest for us we have x-train
X test y train y test and so we go ahead
and train test split X Y random State
equals one it makes it nice and easy for
us we'll go and run that and so now we
have our training and our testing train
means we're going to use that to train
the model and then we're going to use
the test to test to see how good our
model does and then we'll go ahead and
create our model here's our knnn model
the K Neighbors classifier in Neighbors
equals five the metrics is euclidean
remember I talked about euclidean this
is simply your c squared equals a
squared plus b squared plus a squared
equals B squared plus c squared plus c
squared plus D Squared and then you take
the square root of all that that's what
they're talking about here it's just the
length of the hypotenuse of a triangle
but you can actually do that in multiple
Dimensions just like you do in two
Dimensions with the regular triangle and
here we have our fit this should start
to look familiar since we already did
that in our last example that's very
standard for s site kit and any other
one although sometimes the fit
algorithms look a little bit more
complicated because they're doing more
things on there especially when you get
into neural networks and then you have
your key neighbors it just tells you
we've created a k neighbor's setup they
kind of wanted us to reformat the Y but
it's not that big of a deal for this and
it comes out and shows you that we're
using the euclidean metric for our
measurement so now we've created a model
here's our live model we fitted the data
to it we say hey here's our training
data let's go ahead and predict it so
we're going to take our y predict equals
K and N predict y test so this is data
we have not this model has not seen this
data and so we're going to create a
whole new set of data off of there now
before we look at our prediction in fact
let's um I'm going to bring this down
and put it back in here later let's take
a look at our x-test data versus the Y
test what does it look like and so we
have our mean area we're going to
compare it to our mean compactness we're
going to go ahead and run that and we
can see here the data if you look at
this just eyeballing it we put it in
here we have a lot of blue here and we
have a lot of orange here and so these
dots in the middle especially like this
one here and these here these are the
ones that are going to give us false
negatives and so we should expect this
is your noise this is where we're not
sure what it is and then B9 is in this
case it's done in blue and malignant is
done in one so if you look at hit
there's two points based on these
features which makes it really hard to
have a hundred percent where the hundred
percent is down here or up here that's
kind of thing I'd be looking for when
we're talking about cancer and stuff
like that where you really don't want
any false negatives you want everything
you false positive great you're going to
go in there and have another setup in
there where you might get a get an
autopsy or something like that done on
it again that's very data specific on
here so now let's go ahead and pull in
and get our our prediction in here and
we'll create our y prediction we'll go
and run that so now this is loaded with
what we think the unknown data is going
to be and we can go ahead and take that
and go ahead and plot it because it's
always nice to have some pretty pictures
and when we plot it we're going to do
the mean area versus mean compactness
again you look at this map and you can
see that there's some clear division
here we can clearly say on some of the
stuff that our y prediction if we look
at this map up here and this map down
here we probably got some pretty good
deal it looks pretty good like they
match a lot this is of course just
eyeballing it really you don't want to
eyeball these things you want to show
people the pictures so they can see it
you can say hey this is what it looks
like but we really want the confusion
Matrix and we do the Y test and the Y
predict we can see in the confusion
Matrix here it did pretty good and we'll
just go ahead and point that out real
quick here's our 42 which is positive
and our 79 and if I remember correctly
I'd have to look at the data which one
of these is a false negative I believe
it's the nine that's scary I would not
want to be one of those nine people told
that I don't have cancer and then
suddenly find out I do so we would need
to find a way to sort this out and there
is different ways to do that a little
bit past this but you can start messing
with the actual euclidean geometry and
the activation
measurements and start changing those
and how they interact but that's very
Advanced there's also other ways to
classify them or to create a whole other
class right here of we don't knows those
are just a couple of the solutions you
might use for that but for a lot of
things this works out great you can see
here you know maybe you're trying to
sell something well if this was not life
dependent and this was if I display this
ad 42 of these people are going to buy
it and if I display this other ad if I
don't display it 79 people are going to
go a different direction or whatever it
is so maybe you're trying to display
whether they're going to buy something
if you add it on to the website in which
case that's really a good numbers you've
just added a huge number of cells to
your company so that was our K nearest
neighbors let's go ahead and take a look
at support Vector machines so support
Vector machines is the main objective of
a support Vector machine algorithm is to
find a hyperplane in an n-dimensional
space n is the number of features that
distinctly classifies the data points if
you remember we were just looking at
those nice graphs we had earlier in fact
let me go ahead and flip back on over
there if we were looking at this data
here we might want to try to find a nice
line through the data and that's what
we're talking about with this next setup
so the main objective support Vector
machine algorithm is to find a
hyperplane in an n-dimensional space n
is the number of features that
distinctly classifies the data points to
separate the two classes of data there
are many hyperplanes that can be chosen
our objective is to find the plane that
has the maximum margin I.E the maximum
distance between data points of both
classes the dimensions of the hyperplane
depends on the number of features if
there are two input features then the
hyperplane is just a line if there are
three features then the hyperplane
becomes a two-dimensional plane the line
that separates the data into two classes
is called as support vector classifier
or hard margin that's what I just showed
you on the other data you can see here
we look for a line that splits the data
evenly the problem with hard margin is
that it doesn't allow outliers and
doesn't work with none linearly
separable data and we just were looking
at that let me flip back on over here
and when we look at this setup in here
and we look at this data here we go look
how many outliers are in here these are
all with all these blue dots on the
wrong side of the line would be
considered an outlier and the same with
the red line and so it becomes very
difficult to divide this data unless
there's a clear space there we go
therefore we introduce soft margins
which accept the new data point and
optimize a model for non-linear data
points soft margins pass through the
data points at the border of the classes
the support Vector machine can be used
to separate the two classes of shapes
here we can see that although triangles
and diamond shapes have pointy edges but
we are able to classify them in two
categories using a support Vector
machine let's go ahead and see what that
looks like in a demo and flip back on
over to our jupyter notebook we always
want to start with taking a look at the
sklearn API in this case the svm SVC
there is a significant number of
parameters because SK the svm has been a
lot of development in the recent years
and has become very popular if we scroll
all the way down to methods you'll see
right here as our fit and our predict
that's what you should see in most of
the scikit learn packages so this should
look very familiar to what we've already
been working on and we'll go ahead and
bring in our import and run that we
should already have pandas numpy our
matplot library which we're going to be
using to graph some of the things a
little bit different right here you'll
see that we're going to go ahead and
bring in one of the fun things you can
do with test data is make circles
circles are really hard to classify you
have a ring on the inside and a ring on
the outside and you can see where that
can cause some issues and we'll take a
look at that a little closer in a minute
here's our svm setup on there and then
of course our metrics because we're
going to use that to take a closer look
at things so we go and run run this oops
already did once we've gone ahead and
done that we're going to go ahead and
start making ourselves some data and
this part probably a little bit more
complicated than we need I'm not going
to go too much in detail on it we're
going to make a mesh grid and we'll see
what that looks like in a minute we're
defining the minimums you can see in
here create a measurement of points
here's our parameters of x y and H it's
going to return xxyy you can also send a
note to us make sure you get a copy of
this if you want to dig deeper into this
particular code specially and we have a
y Min y Max Y Man y Max plus one here's
our mesh grid we're actually going to
make XX and YY plot the Contours all the
way through and this is just a way of
creating data it's kind of a fun way to
create some data we go plot Contours ax
c l f x x y y and return it out add some
perimeters here so that when we're doing
it we have our setup on there train
property and then we'll go ahead and
make our data just throw that right in
there too in the same setup and run that
so now we have X and Y we're going to
make our circles we have n samples
equals samples in this case we're going
to have 500 samples we went ahead and
gave it a noise of 0.05 random State
123. these are all going into let's go
back up here we go make our mesh grid
make circles there it is so this is
going into our make circles up here and
this is part of that setup on this and
then once we've gone ahead and make the
circle let's go ahead and plot it that
way you can see we're talking about
right now what I'm saying is really
confusing because without a visual it
doesn't really mean very much what we're
actually doing so let me go ahead and
run this with the plot and let's go back
up here and just take a look we've made
our Circle we have our n samples equals
samples we're going to have 500 we're
going to have training property 0.8
here's our data frame we go and load it
into the data frame so we can plot it
groups DF Group by label this is kind of
a fun way if you have multiple columns
you can really quickly pull whatever
setup is in there and then we go ahead
and plot it and you can see here we have
two rings that are formed and that's all
this is doing is just making this data
for us this is really hard data to
figure out a lot of programs get
confused in this because there's no
straight line or anything like that but
we can add planes and different setups
on here and so you can see we have some
very interesting data we have our zero
is in blue and our ones in the yellow in
the middle and the data points are an x
y coordinate plot on this one of the
things we might want to do on here is go
ahead and find the Min to Max ratio set
up in there and we can even do let's
just do a print X you can see what the
data looks like that we're producing on
this there we go so x equals x minus X
Min over x max minus X Min all we're
doing is putting this between 0 and 1.
whatever this data is we want a 0 to 1
setup on here if you look at this all
our data is 0.8.5 that's what this
particular line is doing that's a pretty
common thing to do in processing data
especially in neural networks neural
networks don't like big numbers they
create huge biases and cause all kinds
of problems and that's true in a lot of
our models some of the models it doesn't
really matter but when you're doing
enough of these you just start doing
them you just start putting everything
between zero and one there's even some
algorithms to do that in the SK learn
although it's pretty as you can see it's
pretty easy to do it here so let's go
ahead and jump into the next thing which
is a linear kind of setup C equals 1.0
this is the svm regularization parameter
we're going to use models here's our svm
and this one's just a notch there we go
so here we are with our model we're
going to create the the setup with the
SBC kernel is linear and we'll come back
to that because that's an important uh
setup in there as far as what our kernel
is and you'll you'll see why that's so
important here in a minute because we're
going to look at a couple of these and
so this one is we're actually going to
be changing how that processes it uh and
then our C here's our one our Point O
and then the rest of this is plotting
we're just adding titles making the
Contours so it's a pretty graph you can
actually spend this would be a whole
class just to do all the cool things you
can do with Scatter Plots and regular
plots and colors and things like that in
this case we're going to create a graph
with a nice white line down the middle
so that you can see what's going on here
and when we do this you can see that as
it as it split the data the linear did
just that it drew a line through the
data and it says this is supposed to be
blue and this is supposed to be red and
it doesn't really fit very well that's
because we used a linear division of the
data and it's not very linear data on it
it's anything but linear so when we when
we look at that it's like well okay that
didn't work what's the next option well
there's a lot of choices in here one of
them is just simply we can change this
from the kernel being linear to poly and
we'll just go back up here and use the
same chart oops here we go so here we go
linear kernel we'll change this to poly
and then when we come in here and create
our model here's our model up here
linear we can actually just go right in
and change this to the poly model and if
you remember when we go back over here
to the SVC and let's scroll back up here
there's a lot of different options oops
even further okay so we come up here and
we start talking about the kernel here's
the kernel there's linear there's poly
RBF sigmoid pre-computed there's a lot
of different ways to do this setup and
their actual default is RBF very
important to note that so when you're
running these models understanding which
parameter is really has a huge effect on
what's going on in this particular one
with the svm the kernel is so important
you really need to know that and we
switched our kernel to poly and when we
run this you can see it's changed a
little bit we now have quite an
interesting looking diagram and you can
see on here it now has these
classifications correct but it messes up
in this blue up here and it messes up on
this blue is correct and this blue is
supposed to be red you can see that it
still isn't quite fitting on there and
so that is we do a polyfit you can see
if you have a split in data where
there's a group in the middle this one
kind of data and the groups on the
outside are different the polyfit or the
poly kernels what's going to be fit for
that so if that doesn't work then what
are we going to use well they have the
RBF kernel and let's go ahead and take a
look and see what the RBF looks like and
let me go and turn there we go turn my
drawing off and the RBF kernel oops
RBF and then of course for our title
it's always nice to have it match with
the r b f kernel and we go ahead and run
this and you can see that the RBF kernel
does a really good job it actually has
divided the date app on here and this is
the kind of what you expect here was
that ring here's our inner ring and an
outer ring of data so the RBF fits this
data package quite nicely and that we
talk about svm it really is powerful in
that it has this kind of sorting feature
to it in its algorithms this is
something that is really hard to get the
SK means to do or the k-means setup and
so when you start looking at these
different machine learning algorithms
understanding your data and how it's
grouped is really important it makes a
huge difference as far as what you're
Computing and what you're doing with it
so that was a demo on the support Vector
certainly you could have done continued
on that and done like a confusion Matrix
and all that kind of fun stuff to see
how good it was and split the data up to
see how it vectorizes the visual on
that's so important it makes a big
difference just to see what it looks
like and that giant donut and why it it
does Circle so well or your poly version
or your linear version so we've looked
at some very numerical kind of setups
where there's a lot of math involved
euclidean geometry that kind of thing a
totally different machine learning
algorithm for approaching this is the
decision trees and there's also forests
that go with the decision trees they're
based on multiple trees combined the
decision tree is a supervised learning
algorithm used for classification it
creates a model that predicts a value of
a Target variable by learning simple
decision rules inferred from the data
features a decision tree is a
hierarchical tree structure where an
internal node represents features or
attribute the branch represents the
decision Rule and each Leaf node
represents the outcome and you can see
here where they have the first one yes
or no and then you go either left or
right and so forth one of the coolest
things about decision trees and I'll see
people actually run a decision tree even
though their final model is different
because the decision tree allows you to
see what's going on you can actually
look at it and say why did you go right
or left what was the choice where's that
break and that is really nice if you're
trying to share that information with
somebody else as to why when you start
getting into the why this is happening
decision trees are very powerful so the
topmost note of a decision tree is known
as the root node it learns to partition
on the basis of the attribute value it
partitions a tree in a recursive manner
so you have your decision node if you
get yes you go down to the next note
that's a decision note and either yes
you go to if it ends on a leaf node then
you know your answer which is yes or no
so there's your there's your in
classification setup on there here's an
example of a decision tree that tells
whether I'll sleep or not at a
particular regular evening mine would be
depending on whether I have the news on
or not do I need to sleep no okay I'll
work uh yes is it raining outside yes
I'll sleep no I'll work so I guess if
it's not raining outside it's harder to
fall asleep where you have that nice
rain coming in and again this is really
cool about a decision tree is I can
actually look at it and go oh I like to
sleep when it rains outside so when
you're looking at all the data you can
say oh this is where the twitch comes in
when it rains outside I'll sleep really
good if it's not raining or if I don't
need sleep then I'm not going to sleep
I'm going to go work so let's go ahead
and take a look at that that looks like
in the code just like we did before we
go ahead and open up the site kit set up
just to say what the decision tree
classifier has you have your parameters
which will look a little bit more in
depth at as we write the code but it has
different ways of splitting it the
strategy used to choose a split at each
node Criterion max depth remember the
tree how how far down do you want it do
you want to take up the space of your
whole computer with a and map every
piece of data or you know the smaller
that number is the smaller the level the
tree is and the less processing it takes
but is also more General so you're less
likely to get as in depth and answer
um and then of course minimal samples
you need for to split samples for the
leaves there's a lot of things in here
as far as what how big the tree is and
how to define it and when do you define
it and how to weight it and they have
their different attributes which you can
dig deeper into that can be very
important if you want to know the why of
things and then we go down here to our
methods and you'll see just like
everything else we have our fit method
very important and our predict the two
main things that we use what is what
we're going to predict our X to be equal
to and we'll go ahead and go up here and
start putting together the code we're
going to import our numpy our pandas
there's our confusion Matrix our train
test Split Decision tree classifier
that's the big one that we're actually
working with that's the line right here
where we're going to be oops decision
tree there it is decision tree
classifier that's the one I was looking
for and of course we want to know the
accuracy and the classification report
on here and we're going to do a little
different than we did in the other
examples
and there's a reason for this let me go
and run this and load this up here we're
going to go ahead and build things on
functions and this is when you start
splitting up into a team this is the
kind of thing you start seeing a lot
more both in teams and for yourself
because you might want to swap one data
to test it on a different data depending
on what's going on so we're going to
have our import data here the data set
length the balance and so forth this
just returns balanced data let me just
go ahead and print because I'm curious
as to what this looks like import data
and it's going to return the balance
data so if I run that if we go ahead and
print this out here and run that you can
see that we have a whole bunch of data
that comes in there and some interesting
setup on here has let's see brrr I'm not
sure exactly what that represents on
here uh one one one one one two and so
forth so we have a different set of data
here the shape is 5 of columns one two
three four five seems to have a number
at the beginning which I'm going to
guess
brl a letter I mean and then a bunch of
numbers in there one one one one let's
see down here we got five five five uh
set up on this and let's see balance
data and since it said balance data I'm
going to guess that b means balanced R
means you need to move it right and L
means it needs to be moved left or
skewed to left I'm not sure which one
let's go and close that out and we'll go
ahead and create a function to split the
data set X balance data equals data
values y balance equals data values of
zero there's that letter remember left
right and balance and then we're looking
for the values of one through five and
we go ahead and split it just like you
would X train y train set random State
100 test size is 0.3 so we're taking
thirty percent of the data and it's
going to return your X your y your y
train your your X train your X test your
y train your your y test again we do
this because if you're running a lot of
these you might want to switch how you
split the data and how you train it I
tend to use a bifold method I'll take a
third of the data and I'll train it on
the other two thirds and test it on that
third and then I'll switch it I'll
switch which third is a test data and
then I can actually take that
information and correlate it and it
gives me a really robust package for
figuring out what the complete accuracy
is but in this case we're just going to
go ahead this is our function for
splitting data and this is where it kind
of gets interesting because remember
we're talking a little bit about the
different settings in our model and so
in here we're going to create a decision
tree but we're going to use the genie
setup and where did that come from
what's the genie on here so if we go
back to the top of their page and we
have what Criterion are we going to use
we're going to use Genie they have Genie
and entropy those are the two main ones
that they use for the decision tree so
this one's going to be Genie and if
we're going to have a function that
creates the Genie model and it even goes
down here and here's our fit train of
the Genie model uh we'll probably also
want to create one for entropy sometimes
I even just I might even make this just
one function with the different setups
and I know one of my one of the things I
worked on recently I had to create a one
that tested across multiple models and
so I would send the parameters to the
models or I would send this part right
here where it says decision tree
classifier that whole thing might be
what I send to create the model and I
know it's going to fit we're going to
have our X train and we're gonna have
our predict and all that stuff is the
same so you can just send that model to
your function for testing different
models again this just gives you one of
the ways to do it and you can see here
we're going to chain train with the
genie and we're also going to change
train with the entropy to see how that
works and if you're going to have your
models going two separate models you're
sending there we'll go ahead and create
a prediction this simply is our y
predict equals our whatever object we
sent whatever model we sent here the clf
object and predict against our X test
and you can see here print y predict and
return y predict set up on here and
we'll load that definition up and then
if you're going to have a function that
runs a predict and print some things out
we should also have our accuracy
function so here's our calculate the
accuracy what are we sending we're
sending our y test data this could also
be y actual and Y predict and then we'll
print out a confusion Matrix and then
we'll print out the accuracy of the
score on here and print a report
classification report bundle it all
together there so if we bring this all
together we have all the steps we've
been working towards which is imp
importing our data by the ways you'll
spend eighty percent of your time
importing data in most machine learning
setups and cooking it and burning it and
getting it formatted so that it it works
with whatever models you're working with
the decision tree has some cool features
in that if you're missing data it can
actually pick that up and just skip that
it says I know how to split this there's
no way of knowing whether it rained or
didn't rain last night so I'll look at
something else like whether you watched
TV after eight o'clock you know that
blue screen thing so we have our
function importing our data set we bring
in the data we split the data so we have
our X text test and Y train and then we
have our different models our clf Genie
so it's a decision tree classifier using
the genie setup and then we can also
create the model using entropy and then
once we have that we have our function
for making the prediction and we have
our function for calculating the
accuracy and then if you're going to
have that we should probably have our
main code involved here this probably
looks more familiar if you're depending
on what you're working on if you're
working on like a and Pie charm then you
would see this in throwing something up
real quick in Jupiter notebook uh so
here's our our main data import which
we've already defined we get our split
data we create our Genie we create our
entropy so there's our two models going
on here there's our two models so these
are two separate data models we've
already sent them to be trained then
we're going to go ahead and print the
results using Genie index so we'll start
with the genie and we want to go ahead
with the genie and print our our
predictions Y X test to the genie and
calculate the accuracy on here and then
we want to print the results using
entropy so this is just the same thing
coming down like we did with the genie
we're going to put out our y predict
entropy and our calculations so let's go
ahead and run that and just see what
this piece of code does we do have like
one of our data needs to be is getting a
warning on there that's nothing major
because it's just a simple warning
probably an update of a new version is
coming out uh and so here we are we have
our data set it's got 625 you can
actually see an example of the data set
B meaning balanced I guess and here's
our five data points one one one means
it's balanced it's skewed to the right
with one one one two and so forth on
here and then we're going to go ahead
and predict from our prediction whether
it's to the right or to the left you
could think of a washing machine that's
ski that's banging on one side of the
thing or maybe it's an automated car or
down the middle of the road that's in
balance and it starts going varying to
the right so we need to correct for it
and when we print out the confusion
Matrix we have three different variables
RL and B so we should see the three
different variables on here and you have
as far as whether it predicts in this
case the balance there's not a lot of
balanced loads on here and didn't do a
good job guessing whether it's balanced
or not that's what I take from this
first one the second one I'm guessing is
the right so it did pretty good job
guessing the right balance you can see
that about much of them came up left
unbalanced probably not good for an
automated car because it tells you 18
out of the uh 18 missed things and tells
you to go the wrong direction and here
we are going the other way 19 to 71 and
of course we can back that up with an
accuracy report on here and you can see
the Precision how well the left and
right balance is 79 79 precision and so
forth and then we went and used the
entropy and let me just see if we can
get so we can get them both next to each
other here's our entropy of our the
first setup our first model which is the
Genie model 67 18 1971 63 22 2070 pretty
close the two models that you know
that's not a huge difference in numbers
this second one of entropy did slightly
it looks like slightly worse because it
did one better as far as the right
balance and did what is this four worse
on the left balance or whatever uh so
slightly worse if I was guessing between
these I'd probably use the first one
they're so close though that wouldn't be
it wouldn't be a Clear Choice as to
which one worked better and there's a
lot of numbers you can play with here
which might give better results
depending on what the data is going in
now one of the takeaways you should have
from the different category routines we
ran is that they run very similar you
certainly change the perimeters in them
as to whether you're using what model
you're using and how you're using it and
what data they get applied to but when
you're talking about the site kit learn
in package it does such an awesome job
of making it easy you split your data up
you train your data and you run the
prediction and then you see what kind of
accuracy what can confusion confusion
Matrix It generates so we talk about
algorithm selection logistic regression
K nearest neighbors logistic regression
is used when we have a binomial outcome
for example to predict whether an email
is Spam or not whether the tumor is
malignant or not the logistic regression
works really good on that you can do it
in a k nearest neighbors also the
question is which one will it work
better in I find a logistic regression
models work really good in a lot of raw
numbers so if you're working with say
the stock market is this a good
investment or a bad investment so that's
one of the things that it handles the
numbers better Kate nearest neighbors
are used in scenarios where
non-parametric no fixed number of
parameters algorithms are required it is
used in pattern recognition Data Mining
and and intrusion detection so K means
really good in finding the patterns I've
seen that as a preprocessor to a lot of
other processors where you use the K
nearest neighbors to figure out what
data groups together very powerful
package support Vector machines support
Vector machines are used whenever the
data has higher Dimensions the human
genome microarray svms are extensively
used in the hard handwriting recognition
models and you can see that we were able
to switch between the parabolic and the
circular setup on there where you can
now have that donut kind of data and be
able to filter that out with the support
Vector machine and then decision trees
are mostly used in operational
researches specifically in decision
analysis to help identify a strategy
most likely to reach any goal they are
preferred where the model is easy to
understand
I like that last one it's a good
description is it easy to understand so
you have data coming in when am I going
to go to bed you know was it raining
outside you can go back and actually
look at the pieces and see those
different decision modes takes a little
bit more to dig in there and figure out
what they're doing but you can do that
and you can actually help you figure out
why people love it for the Y Factor so
uh strengths and limitations big one on
all of these the strengths and
limitations we talk about logistic
regressions uh the strings are is easy
to implement and efficient to train it
is relatively easy to regularize the
data points remember how we put
everything between zero and one when you
look at logistic regression models you
don't have to worry about that as much
limitations as a high Reliance on proper
representation of data It could only
predict a categorical outcome with the K
nearest neighbors it doesn't need a
separate training period new data can be
added seamlessly without effect acting
the accuracy of the model kind of an
interesting thing because you can do
partial training that can become huge if
you're running across a really large
data sets or the data's coming in it can
continually do a partial fit on the data
with the K nearest neighbors and
continue to adjust that data uh it
doesn't doesn't work on high dimensional
and large data sets we were looking at
the breast cancer 36 different features
what happens when you have 127 features
or a million features and you say well
what do you have a million features in
well if I was analyzing Logic the legal
documents I might have a tokenizer that
splits a words up to be analyzed and
that tokenizer might create one million
different words available that might be
in the document for doing weights
sensitive to noisy data outliers and
missing values that's a huge one with K
nearest neighbors they really don't know
what to do with the missing value how do
you compute the the distance if you
don't know what the value is
uh The svm Works more efficiently on
high dimensional data it is relatively
memory efficient so it's able to create
those planes with only a few different
variables in there as opposed to having
to store a lot of data for different
features and things like that it's not
suitable for a large data sets the svm
you start running this over gigabytes of
data causes some huge issues
underperforms if the data has noise or
overlapping that's a big one we were
looking at that where the svm splits it
and it creates a soft buffer but what
happens when you have a lot of stuff in
the middle that's hard to sort out
doesn't know what to do with that causes
svm to start crashing or not perform as
well decision trees handles non-linear
perimeters and missing values
efficiently the missing values is huge
I've seen this in was it the wine
tasting data sets where they have three
different data sets and they share
certain features but then each one has
some features that aren't in the other
other ones and it has to figure out how
to handle those well the decision tree
does that automatically instead of
having to figure a way to fill that data
in before processing like you would with
the other models it's easy to understand
and has less training period so it
trades pretty quickly comes up there and
just keeps forking the tree down and
moving the parts around and so it
doesn't have to go through the data
multiple times guessing and adjusting it
just creates the tree as it goes
overfitting and high variants are the
most annoying part of it that's that's
an understatement uh that has to do with
how many leaves and how many decisions
you have it do the more you have the
more overfit it is to the data it also
just in making the choices and how the
choices come in it might overfit to a
specific feature because that's where it
started at and that's what it knows and
it really is challenged with large data
sets they've been working on that with
the data Forest but it's not suitable
for large data sets it's really
something you'd probably run on a single
machine and not across not a cry across
a data pool or anything station tree one
of the many powerful tools in the
machine learning library begins with a
problem I think I have to buy a car so
in making this question you want to know
how do I decide which one to buy and
you're going to start asking questions
is the mileage greater than 20 is a
price less than 15 will it be sufficient
for six people does it have enough
airbag anti-lock brakes all these
questions come up then as we feed all
this data in we make a decision and that
decision comes up oh hey this seems like
a good idea here's a car so as we go in
through this decision process using a
decision tree we're going to explore
this maybe not in buying a car but in
how to process data what's in it for you
let's start by finding out what is
machine learning and why we even want to
know about it for processing our data
and we'll go into the three basic types
of machine learning and the problems
that are used by Machine learning to
solve finally we'll get into what is a
decision tree what are the problems that
decision tree solves what are the
advantages and disadvantages of using a
decision tree and then we want to dig in
a little deep into the mechanics how
does the decision tree work and then
we'll go in and do a case loan repayment
prediction where we actually are going
to put together some python code and
show you the basic python code for
generating a decision tree what is
machine learning there are so many
different ways to describe what is
machine learning in today's world and
illustrate it we're going to take a
graphic here and making decisions or
trying to understand what's going on and
really underlying machine learning is
people want to wish they were smarter
wish we could understand the world
better so you can see a guy here who's
uh saying hey how can I understand the
world better and someone comes up and
says let's use artificial intelligence
machine learning is a part of artificial
intelligence and that always gets a big
smile on his face because now he has
artificial intelligence to help him make
his decisions and they can think in new
ways so this brings in new ideas so what
is machine learning this is a wonderful
graph here you can see where we have a
learn predict decide these are the most
basic three premises of machine learning
in learning we can describe have the
data in new ways and able to learn new
aspects about what we're looking at and
then we can use that to predict things
and we can use that to make decisions so
maybe it's something that's never
happened before but we can make a good
guess whether it's going to be a good
investment or not it also helps us
categorize stuff so we can remember it
better so it's easier to pull it out of
the catalog we can analyze data in new
ways we never thought possible and then
of course there's the very large growing
industry of recognize we can do facial
recognition driver recognition automated
car recognition all these are part of
machine learning going back to our guy
here who's in his ordinary system and
would like to be smarter make better
choices what happens with machine
learning is an application of artificial
intelligence wherein the system gets the
ability to automatically learn and
improved based on experience so this is
exciting because you have your ordinary
guy who now has another form of
information coming in and this is with
the artificial intelligence helps him
see things he never saw or track things
he can't track so instead of having to
read all the news feeds he can now have
an artificial intelligence sorted out so
he's only looking at the information he
needs to make a choice with and of
course we use all those machine learning
tools back in there and he's now making
smarter choices with less work types of
machine learning let's break it into
three primary types of learning first is
supervised learning where you already
have the data and the answers so if you
worked at a bank you'd already have a
list of all the previous loans and who
defaulted on them and who made good
payments on them you then program your
machine learning tool and that lets you
predict on the next person whether
they're going to be able to make their
payments or not on their loan if you
have one category we already know the
answers the next one would be you don't
know the answers you just have a lot of
information coming in unsupervised
learning allows you to group liked
information together so if you're
analyzing photos it might group all the
images of trees together and all the
images of houses together without even
knowing what a house or a tree is which
leads us to the third type of machine
learning the third type of machine
learning is reinforcement learning
unlike supervised or unsupervised
learning you don't have the data prior
to starting so you get the data one line
at a time and then whether you make a
good choice or a bad choice the machine
learning tool has to then adjust
accordingly so you get a plus or minus
feedback you can liken this to the way a
human learns we experience life one
minute at a time and we learn from that
and either our memories is good or we
learn to avoid some problems in machine
learning to understand where the
decision tree fits into our machine
learning tools we have to understand the
basics of some of the machine learning
problems and three of the primary ones
fall underneath classification problems
with categorical Solutions like yes or
no true or false one or zero this might
be does it belong to a particular group
yes or no then we have regression
problems where there's a continuous
value needs to be predicted like product
prices profit and you can see here this
is a very simple linear graph you can
guess what the next value is based on
the first four it kind of follows a
straight line going up and clustering
this is problems where the data needs to
be organized to find specific patterns
like in the case of product
recommendation they group all the
different products that people just like
you viewed on a shopping site and say
people who bought this also bought this
the most commonly used for the decision
tree is for classification for figuring
out is it red or is it not is it a fruit
or is it a vegetable yes or no true
false left or right zero one and so we
talk about classification we're going to
look at the basic machine learning these
are the four main tools used in
classification there's a Nave Bays
logistic regression decision tree and
random Forest the first two are for
simpler data so if your data is not very
complex you can usually use these to do
a fairly good representation by drawing
a line through the data or a curve
through the data they work Wonderful in
a lot of problems but as things get more
complicated the decision tree comes in
and then if you have a very large amount
of data you start getting into the
random Forest so the decision tree is
actually a part of the random Forest but
today we're just going to focus on the
decision tree
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shape
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is a diameter greater than two if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression when we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the Target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data High variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to be
using we'll start with entropy entropy
is a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is Information
Gain Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
Information Gain is simply the entropy
E1 from the top and how it's changed to
E2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
Python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math and how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node Leaf node
carries a classification or the decision
so it's a final end at the bottom the
decision node has two or more branches
this is where we're breaking the group
up into different parts and finally you
have the root node the topmost decision
node is known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals I'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with a gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
Information Gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e the funky e of K where I
equals 1 to k k would represent the
number of animal the different animals
in there where value or P value of I
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log base 2 of the same the
percentage of that animal let's try to
calculate the entropy for the current
data set and take a look at what that
looks like and don't be afraid of the
math don't really have to memorize this
math just be aware that it's there and
this is what's going on in the
background and so we have three drafts
two tigers one monkey two elephants a
total of eight animals gather and if we
plug that into the formula we get an
entropy that equals three over eight so
we have three drafts a total of eight
times the log usually they use base two
on the log so log base 2 of 3 over 8
plus in this case let's say it's the
elephants two over eight two elephants
over a total of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over a
total of eight log base 2 1 over 8 and
plus two 2 over 8 of the Tigers log base
2 over 8. and if we plug that into our
computer or calculator I obviously can't
do logs in my head we get an entropy
equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a Formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has to decreased considerably however we
still need some splitting at both the
branches to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
the nodes using height as the condition
since every Branch now contains single
label type we can say that entropy in
this case has reached the least value
and here you see we have the giraffes of
the Tigers the monkey and the elephants
all separate into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with the
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some Python and see what the programming
code and the scripting looks like in
here we're going to want to do a
prediction and we start with this
individual here who's requesting to find
out how good his customers are going to
be whether they're going to repay their
loan or not for the bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
Python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
Python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing I need is
I need something to edit my Python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
I'm using the Anaconda Jupiter notebook
now you can use any python IDE you like
to run it in but I find the jupyter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the Fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we we start let's talk a little
bit about what we're bringing in and
then we're going to do a couple things
in here we have to make a couple changes
as we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as NP that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with a very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
numbers it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as PD
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an Excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see NP or PD those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and I'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so I'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sklearn package cross
validation and just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the SK dot
tree import decision tree classifier
that's the actual tool we're using
remember I told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you well the decision tree
classifier has all that mathematics in
there for you so you don't have to
figure it back out again and then we
have sklearn.metrix for accuracy score
we need to score our our setup that's
the whole reason we're splitting it
between the training and testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree and that's just the basic
tree function that's needed for the
decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and I'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says I need to read a file and when this
was written the person who wrote it this
is their path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and I'm going to put in here my file
path I'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my C drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where I stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different the data.2 CSV file was
generated by simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the YouTube
and then if I'm going to give it a name
full file name
I'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up is probably the
hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed and it's
going to be moved in favor of the model
selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with model
selection
and so when I come in here and I run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further I went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore 2.csv let's talk a little bit
more about that and see what that looks
like both as a text file because it's a
comma separated variable file and in a
spreadsheet this is what it looks like
as a basic text file you can see at the
top they've created a header and it's
got one two three four five columns and
each column has data in it and let me
flip this over because we're also going
to look at this in an actual spreadsheet
so you can see what that looks like and
here I've opened it up in the open
Office calc which is pretty much the
same as Excel and zoomed in and you can
see we've got our columns and our rows
of data a little easier to read in here
we have a result yes yes no we have
initial payment last payment credit
score house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data I usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so I can see what I'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in Python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple Lin
function from python
and when I run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the column
head this is one of the nice things when
we did the balance data from the panda
read CSV you'll see that the header is
row zero so it automatically removes a
row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that and again
we're going to utilize the tools in
panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using Python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data.head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and when we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
Excel spreadsheet or open Office Cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to First
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
site to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our X and Y
where did X and Y come from well X is
going to be our data
and Y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at it source and
Target
in this case we're using X and Y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets means that we're going to
select all the lines in the database so
it's all the data and the second one
says we're only going to look at columns
one through five remember always start
with zero zero is a yes or no and that's
whether the loan went default or not so
we want to start with one if we go back
up here that's the initial payment and
it goes all the way through the house
number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for Y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your X training your X
test your y train your y test
simply put we have X going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have X test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the Y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the X train and since we know the
answers for X trade or the Y train we go
and put those in and let's go ahead and
run this and what most of these sklearn
modules do is when you set up the
variable in this case when we set the
clf entropical decision tree classifier
it automatically prints out what's in
that decision tree there's a lot of
variables you can play Within here and
it's quite beyond the scope of this
tutorial real to go through all of these
and how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves as five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so I'll have at least three splits I'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created our decision tree classifier not
only created it but trained it let's go
ahead and apply it and see what that
looks like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what it's doing here we
have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sklearn modules that
they're different tools have the predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our X
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not in this case we need to
test out the data and just see how good
our sample is how good of our tree does
at predicting the loan payments and
finally since Anaconda Jupiter notebook
is works as a command line for python we
can simply put the Y predict en to print
it I could just as easily have put the
print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out and we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it
and you'll see right here that it runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our why predict came
out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrix import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict en
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage and let's run that
and see what it looks like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
a decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not and now we were thrilled
to present our AI bootcamp that is
designed to equip you with the knowledge
and skills you need to thrive in this
fast-paced and ever evolving field in
this six months intensive and immersive
learning experience you will have the
opportunity to dive head first into the
subject matter gaining hands-on
experience and building a strong
foundation in AI we believe in a
practical approach where you will work
on 25 plus Hands-On projects across
various industry verticals providing you
with real world experience but sets a
boot camp apart is our partnership with
Caltech CDMA ensuring academic
excellence and Industry recognition by
successfully completing the boot camp
you will earn a prestigious certificate
and up to 22 CU credits from caltex ctma
validating your expertise in the field
so are you ready to embark on this
transformative Journey are you ready to
unlock the power of AI and take your
career to new heights if so enroll in
our AI boot camp today and become part
of the AI Revolution the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
ever get stuck while writing an email
finding the right words or stuck on that
article you can't find the final words
for well to get rid of this writer's
block a my rate of AI tools help you
achieve your targets we are now at a
time when artificial intelligence stands
to do many jobs better and more
efficiently due to the lack of human
error it's not just content creation AI
can find use in a ton of scenarios let
us go through some of the best AI tools
available today that can boost your
productivity at number 10 you have magic
eraser by Magic Studio Magic Eraser
removes unwanted images from your
pictures using artificial intelligence
it can decipher the backgrounds and
remove unnecessary elements out of a
picture beat unwanted Birds on a
landscape shots or branding on social
media posts select the element to be
removed using the Eraser and let the
Tool Work its magic next at number 9 we
have the thing translator this tool
allows users to point their camera at an
object and hear the translation in a
different language using the cloud
Vision API and the translate API of
Google the translator serves as a godson
for foreign Travelers or just people
trying to learn a new language with both
the Google apis set to develop even more
over time expect the thing translator to
become more helpful than ever at number
8 we have tab 9. tab 9 analyzes and
recommends your next blocks of code
based on the context and syntax get
lengthy accurate and create creative
code completions to become a more
efficient developer cabinet's AI
completions may be executed on a
developer's laptop behind a firewall or
even on the cloud it recommends code
completions based on your coding
Tendencies it supports the most common
languages such as JavaScript Python and
typescript and even more Niche languages
such as rust go and Bash irrespective of
what your Tech stack looks like tab 9
will boost your speed at number 7 we
have Trevor AI travel AI is a daily
planning program that leverages
intelligent time blocking to connect
your list of activities and calendar it
supports integration and two-way sync
with services like Google Calendar and
todoist taking control of how you spend
your time based on schedules and time
frames it helps plan your habits and
work life to create a streamlined
approach to your day using artificial
intelligence this helps you focus on the
individual task rather than worrying
about cramming your busy schedule into
the entire day at number 6 we have deep
Nostalgia deep Nostalgia is an online
tool developed by a company called
myheritage and can animate faces from
old pictures my Heritage licensed this
unique technology for animating
photographs from did which is a firm
specializing in video reconstruction
using deep learning myheritage uses
technology to animate the faces in Old
images and generate high quality
lifelike video footage the tool Works
equally well for black and white
pictures and photographs taken in color
so needless to say the results are
pretty astonishing and can be quite
moving in many cases number five on our
list goes to durable durable helps
create sample websites in under 30
seconds for people starting a new
business or who are generally not well
versed in web development just choose
the type of business you are running and
the name of your company to get sample
designs made immediately from spaces
assigned to customer reviews to buttons
allotted for social media profiles
durables ensures the websites match the
latest trends in web development you can
restyle the colors and headings or sign
up to further customize the website
based on your requirements at number 4
we have Jasper with the growth of AI
everything it's only a matter of time
until AI is utilized to produce content
for your blog social networks websites
and other platforms Jasper AI formerly
known as Jarvis is a low cost service
that generates original materials such
as blog entries for you it's simple
enough for almost anyone to use all you
have to do is enter general information
about what you want to address and the
AI will do the rest providing over 50
templates Jasper can handle a
significant amount of the heavy lifting
for topics that are often written about
the AI can provide a solid foundation of
information to which you can
subsequently add your own unique Insight
number three on our list goes to Tetra
with Tetra you don't have to note down
your minutes of meeting every day Tetra
dials into your calls and essentially
takes notes for you allowing you to
focus on the discussion now and remember
all of it later authentic speech
recognition has yet to reach the level
where it can function as a viable
alternative jetra also has a notes
viewer with each audio byte synced with
the notes this level of detail allows
you to focus on the meetings discussion
without making individual notes
throughout the call at number 2 we have
the dolly A2 the latest groundbreaking
text to picture generator from openai is
called to only do it enables users to
produce visuals in response to text cues
users can use this generator to
transform the imaginative thoughts into
lifelike Graphics if you scroll through
Twitter and look for the hashtag dolly2
you will be greeted with many images and
artworks shared by many people based on
different topics from Victorian era
style pictures of aliens to just plain
portrait style images Dolly 2 has all
its bases covered regarding variety the
AI is taught by a deep learning how to
make text to image associations which
the model later uses to recreate the
relevant images finally we have chat GPT
at number one openai has unveiled chat
GPT a powerful new chatbot that uses an
improved version of its AI technology to
Converse in plain English while GPT has
existed for a while this model has
reached a critical point it is
beneficial for a broad range of
activities from developing software to
generating company ideas to composing a
wedding toast while prior iterations of
the program could potential actually
execute these tasks the output quality
was far worse than that of a typical
person since its debut Twitter has been
bombarded with people using it for
unusual and bizarre purposes such as
creating weight loss strategies and
children's novels and providing
instructions on retrieving a peanut
butter sandwich from a VCR it seems chat
GPT will serve as an important Monument
for artificial intelligence to be
welcomed in the consumer sphere so that
wraps up our video on the top 10 AI
tools for 2023 ever wondered how Google
Maps can provide the fastest route
almost instantly have you ever
considered the speed and accuracy of
virtual Bots like Google assistant or
Siri
all of them are powered by artificial
technology AI for short
riding on the data science hype train
the global AI Market is projected to go
from around 87 billion dollars in 2021
to nearly 1600 billion dollars by 2030.
artificial intelligence has impacted
almost all sectors of the ID domain but
its significance in the robotics
industry is unmatched even Tesla has
announced a new humanoid robot meme
Optimus recently built to perform daily
activities and helped in Tesla factories
in today's video let's go through some
of the most advanced artificial
intelligence based robots Paving the way
for a faster and smarter future in 2023
before we start here's a question for
the AI Enthusiast watching this video
which one of the following is not an
example of AI is it in computer vision
is it be web design is it C voice
recognition or D robotic
please leave your answers in the
comments below and that's a cue to get
started with the top 10 EI robots for
number 10 on our list is iPhone
able is a channel neutral robot dog
created by Sony this robot was retired
nearly a decade ago but has been brought
back with even greater human operation
capabilities
this artificial puppy responds to words
of Praise or head scratches can learn
tricks and seeks out owners
a very important feature of IBO is that
it has an app that owners can use to
alter system settings or add new tricks
and store Memories by connecting to the
cloud AI system
next on number nine we have spot
former sport robot also known as spot
mini is really a four-legged robot
produced by Boston Dynamics an American
robotics company
spot is 83 centimeters tall and weighs
only 25 kg
sport can perform various tasks
including walking stairs and navigating
rugged terrain it's small enough to be
used indoors as well
Xbox unique selling point is that it can
go places other wheeled robots cannot
all while carrying carcos of up to 14
kilogram of examination gear on number
eight we have Serena 4 Serena 4 is a
humanoid robot created by scientists at
the University of Tehran the fourth
generation of Iran Serena robot can
imitate a human position grip a water
bottle and write its name on a
whiteboard the robot which took four
years to develop can track objects
properly and its new hands permitted to
manipulate various objects from delicate
gestures to using Power Equipment
however the improvements are not only
internal Serena Force exterior has been
updated with new plastic panels making
the robot appear sleek and just slightly
threatening
next we have Aqua knot at number seven
Equinox is a shape-shifting underwater
robot developed by Houston mechatronics
Incorporated in Texas
The Equinox design allows it to mop from
a sleek and small submarine to a
slightly humanoid form with two extended
arms allowing it to perform various jobs
underwater
was created to address a long-standing
problem in offshore oil and gas which
was the cost of maintaining offshore
sites with no similar device on the
market The Equinox might have a
significant Advantage because it can
accomplish this task without the
inconvenience of being tied to a support
vehicle and with only minimal oversight
from a human operator
at number six we have strontronic
strandtronics are simple animatronics
stunt doubles each strandtronic employs
onboard sensing to perform numerous
flips twists and postures with
repeatability and position combining
modern robotic technology with the
investigation of untethered Dynamic
movement the initiative to investigate
stunt double animatronics began then
attempt to manage the landing of a
figure heard from a window by Walt
Disney Studios meanwhile Disney research
experts worked hard to utilize angular
momentum conservation to enable fine
Airborne motion control a union of the
two projects allowed the team to
construct the strandtronics platform
which is ready to bring a wide range of
dynamic characters to life
number five we have flipping flippy is
an autonomous robotic kitchen assistant
that can assist chefs in preparing
freshly cooked burgers and fried foods
such as crispy chicken tenders and tater
tots
for example while cooking at the grill
it can automatically detect when the raw
burger patties are placed monitor each
Patty in real time and switch between
spatulas for raw and grooming baby's
brain is powered by Cloud connected
artificial intelligence allowing you to
learn from its environment and acquire
new abilities over time next we have
Sofia at number four Sofia is regarded
to be the most intelligent humanoid
robot she made her debut in 2016 and an
interaction with humans was the most
extraordinary thing you'd ever witness
in a machine Hanson robotics based in
Hong Kong developed her to integrate as
an elderly companion in healthcare
facilities or crowd management at events
Sophia is the world's first robot
Citizen and the UN development program's
first robot Innovation Ambassador Sophia
has integrated neural network models and
artificial intelligence to recognize
human faces and interpret the gestures
and emotions at number 3 we have Atlas
Atlas is a humanoid robot created by
Boston Dynamics and renowns for his
unmatched ability to jump over obstacles
do backflips and dance Atlas completes a
parkour track in one of the company's
most recent videos its Evolution has
been nothing short of remarkable aside
from the spectacular acrobatics it
demonstrates some interesting
foundational abilities such as operative
shifting its equilibrium after landing
atlas's Behavior has also been extended
by providing it with a collection of
complete behaviors such as sleeping and
vaulting and allowing it to adapt those
behaviors to the new scenarios advice
next we have pepper in the second
position the pepper robot is among
businesses most sophistically
commercially available social robots
today
SoftBank robotics designed it to be
friendly and engaging as well as to put
people at ease and is equally at home
with infants as it is with adults Peppa
can hold conversations and incorporate
Knowledge from those stocks into his
words it may be trained to recognize
items pick them out in a room and make
decisions to Enlighten or amuse finally
at number one we have Amika engineered
Arts describes Amica as the world's most
advanced human-shaped robot reflecting
The Cutting Edge of human robotics
technology the robot can mimic
Expressions fairly well in response to
all questions articulately engineered
Arts Amica Hardware is based on the
research into human nature Robotics and
is built on the proprietary investment
technology
amica's artificial limbs ligaments
Motors and sensor Aries are made with
Cutting Edge technology as shown in
movies the rise of air usually results
in chaos amica's developers on the other
hand argue that the scientific
breakthrough will be used for a
different purpose claiming that Amica
will serve as a future phase of robots
so that wraps up the top 10 aie power
robots for 2023
phase detection system it is a form of
biometric recognition a method for
identifying or confirming someone's
identity by glancing at their face is
called facial recognition people can be
identified by securing a match on facial
ID using this technique real-time
visuals videos and photos can be the
sources to run face detection this
technology is mostly employed in
security and law enforcement opencv is
the best technology to create it a
python package called opencv is made
specifically to address computer vision
jobs computer vision is a process used
in the processing of images by computers
it is concerned with the in-depth
comprehension of digital photos or films
it is necessary to automate operations
that can be performed by human visual
systems therefore a computer should be
able to identify item like a statue or a
Lamppost or even the face of a human
being
second one is chatbot it is the best
idea if you have chosen chatbot as your
project topic this will make your resume
more attractive in case you are looking
for a job an oracle survey suggests that
80 of the businesses uses chatbot you
can use Python Java Ruby C plus plus or
PHP as a programming language to develop
a chatbot designing and building NLP
chatbots that accept speech and Text
data is made easier by dialog flow you
can go through many projects to get the
rough idea there are many platforms
which will help you to build a chatbot
regardless of how excellent your chatbot
is there is always room for development
the finest chatbot developers constantly
enhance their Bots over the time using
Ai and machine learning social media
recommendation system the rise of web
services like Netflix Amazon and YouTube
has increased the use of recommender
systems in our daily lives they are
algorithms that insist users in finding
information that is pertinent to them
recommender systems are important in
some forms since they can generate a lot
of income or allow you to set yourself
apart from rivals in order to provide
recommendations it evaluates the
relationship between the user and the
object as well as the palace between
users and positions coming to predicting
stock this application is widely
applicable everywhere as AI career
aspirants one will love to develop stock
prediction applications as it is full of
data this project would be ideal for
students who want to work in the finance
industry because it it can provide I
repeat because it can provide them a
better understanding of very various
aspects of the field coming to medical
diagnosis this project is advantageous
from a medical standpoint AI projects
can be created to detect heart-based
diseases and also detect cancer it is
intended to offer patients with heart
illness online medical advice and
guidance after processing the data this
system will search the database for any
illnesses that might be connected to the
given details using data mining
techniques this intelligent system
determines the disease that the
patient's information most closely
resembles
based on the system diagnosis losers can
then speak with qualified medical
professionals users of the system can
also view information about various
doctors coming to an important project
that is search engine search engines are
utilized by all we look for information
on the greatest product to buy a nice
area to hang out or solutions to any
questions we have NLP is quite
significant in modern search engines
because a lot of language processing
takes place there python is the widely
used language to develop any search
engine search engine is mainly confined
with lots and lots of data it is helpful
for any AI career as parents next is
virtual assistants here the challenge is
to build a virtual assistant to assist
user why do you need virtual assistant
in your devices when you are building
your own it is also interesting for a ml
developer to build a virtual assistant
it involves NLP and data mining voice
based virtual assistants are popular
today because they make life easier for
users NLP is utilized to comprehend
human language in order to construct
this system when a voice command is
received the system will translate it
into machine language and store the
commands in its database hate speech
detection in Social social media
automated hate speech detection is a
crucial weapon in the fight against hate
speech propagation especially on social
media for the job many techniques have
been developed including a recent
explosion of deep learning based system
for the objective of detecting hate
speech a number of techniques have been
investigated including conventional
classifiers classifiers based on deep
learning and combination of both of them
on the other hand a number of data set
benchmarks including Twitter sentiment
analysis have been introduced and made
available for the evolution of the
performance of these algorithms and the
last one is predicting house price you
will need to estimate the sale price of
a brand new home in any place for this
assignment the data set for this project
includes information on the cost of
homes in various City neighborhoods the
UCI machine learning repository is the
place where you may find the data set
needed for This research you will also
receive other data set with information
on the age of the population the city's
crime rate and the location of
non-retail Enterprises in addition to
the pricing of various residences it's
an excellent project to test your
knowledge if you are a newbie popular
market research projects that the market
for artificial intelligence will grow
from 59.7 billion dollars in 2021 to
422.4 billion dollars in 2028 artificial
intelligence Automation and Robotics are
disrupting almost every business
companies that don't invest in AI
Services risk becoming obsolete whether
in machine learning smart applications
Appliance digital assistants or
autonomous vehicles
numerous companies stand to benefit from
AI but a handful of them have proven to
be the game changers for 2023 and Beyond
so hey everyone you are already watching
simply learn and here we are with the
list of top 10 AI companies in 2023 if
you love watching videos like these do
hit the Subscribe button to never miss
an update from Simply learn so let's
explore and learn about them one by one
starting with the 10th position which is
uipath robotic process automation or RPA
is a technology developed by uipath that
helps businesses to boost productivity
and reduce cost by automating time
consuming and repetitive operations
software robots can be equipped with
uipath AI Technologies to carry out
duties including reading documents and
emails interpreting language and visual
cues and comprehending the content and
the intent of the communications the RPA
Market is estimated to be worth 38
billion and uipath offers distinct
advantages over the competitors thanks
to its patent computer vision technology
and wide range of Bot Technologies in
the ninth position we have diameteries
the surface is offered by dynatories
include observe availability and
infrastructure monitoring the Davis AI
engine developed by the business can
analyze 368 trillion dependencies each
second Davis can quickly locate problems
in a company's digital ecosystem explain
what went wrong and evaluate and rate
likely commercial ramifications the
company estimated a market Worth to
85.42 million and is poised to grow
Revenue by roughly 20 percent annually
throughout at least 2025 then at the
eighth position we have talented
Technologies data analytics software
startup talented Technologies uses AI to
analyze data according to revenue and
market share parenting was ranked as the
two AI software platform globally by IDC
in September 2022 the United States
intelligence and defense Industries
account for a sizeable portion of
volunteers Revenue the business just won
a new 85.1 million contract from the US
Army Marshall command to assist with the
developing Ai and machine learning
Technologies to enhance equipment
reliability improve predictive
maintenance and improve Supply chains
talented May deliver revenues closer to
the higher end of analysis estimates
roughly 2.5 billion in 2023 then and the
seventh position is workday workday is a
provider of cloud-based applications
with an emphasis on human resources
management with the systems of workdays
distinctive AI based optimized
Innovation engine businesses can manage
challenges with hiring and Staffing
fluctuation labor demand shift
scheduling and prioritizing and more
in April 2022 workday Incorporated
Barrister and AI powered virtual
assistant from espressive into their
platform workday is Raising 2023 markets
Worth to almost 5.53 billion
representing year-over-year growth of 22
percent now in the sixth position we
have intuitive surgical The DaVinci
surgical system offered by intuitive
surgical performs minimally invasive
procedures using Cutting Edge draw
boards and computerized visualization
technology with the help of a big data
and AI intuitive is developing tools
that will help surgeons by improving
their training and offering them
real-time Direction despite the fact
that the DaVinci surgical system has
been approved by usfda for 22 years
intuitive reported a 13 percent
year-over-year increase is installed in
the system most recent quarter the
global intuitive surgical Market is
projected to reach 6.5 billion dollars
by 2023. moving towards the fifth
position we have IBM for years IBM has
been developing strategies to use its AI
supercomputer to alter the legal banking
academic and Healthcare Industries IBM's
clients harness the power of AI to stay
current on average changing regulations
by providing end-to-end risk and
compliance management IBM continues to
dominate the market for the other
breakthroughs in Ai and its Auto Ai and
auto email products can help data
scientists build and improve Ai and
machine learning models the market worth
of IBM in 2023 will range from 14.4
billion to 16 billion following that in
the fourth position is nvidium high-end
chipmaker Nvidia provides the
significant computing power needed for
advanced AI applications in reality one
of the world's fastest supercomputers
Leonardo is powered by Nvidia Graphics
processing units the parent company of
Facebook meta platforms is building the
biggest artificial intelligence
supercomputer in the world meta also
owns nvidia's Quantum infibe and
networking system and 6080 a 100 nvda
Graphics processing processors Nvidia is
a signified supplier for fast growing
Industries like high-end gaming business
Graphics cloud computing artificial
intelligence and advanced automative
technology nvidia's outlook for 2023
revenue is expected to be around 6
billion here comes the top three in the
list and in the third position we have
Amazon AI is integrated into every
aspect of Amazon's business including
e-commerce search engines targeted
advertising and Amazon web services
Amazon Alexa one of the most popular
virtual assistant is already present in
many American Homes Amazon said in
August that it would pay 1.7 billion to
acquire robots Corp RBT a maker of Home
robots this section can allow Amazon to
boost the use of AI in household
worldwide Amazon expects a 491 billion
Market worth between 2023 and 2027. in
the second position is alphabet alphabet
the company that owns Google and YouTube
uses Ai and Automation in practically
every part of business including ad
pricing Gmail spam filters and content
promotion in addition it is the parent
company of the autonomous car
manufacturer waymo and the AI software
business deepmind which created history
in 2022 when it became the first
completely autonomous commercial taxi
service to operate on public roads
the market worth of alphabet in 2023
will be around 70 billion dollars and
the first position on the list is
Microsoft in 2020 Microsoft announced
the construction of a new supercomputer
hosted on Azure Microsoft's cloud
computing Network the supercomputer was
created in collaboration with open AI to
train AI models producing substantial AI
models and related infrastructure for
programmers and other businesses in
October Microsoft released Microsoft
designer a graphic design tool that
makes original social media post
invitations and other Graphics using AI
technology Microsoft the tech giant is
expected to earn a market worth of
49.73 billion and with that we have come
to the end of this list of the top 10 a
artificial intelligence companies of
2023. up
have increased significantly in recent
ly the surge in jobs related to AI is
legitimate due to its widespread
involvement in crucial Fields according
to indeed the pay range for jobs
involving artificial intelligence is
between 160 thousand dollars to three
thousand fifty thousand dollars and can
go even higher so we have come up with a
list of leading career opportunities in
artificial intelligence along with
companies hiring for those roles but
before we begin here is a question for
you who do you think is currently
leading the AI Market let us know in the
comment section below so without any
further delay let's get started starting
with our list we have robotics engineer
an engineer in robotics create
prototypes constructs and test machines
and updates the software that manages
them additionally they investigate the
most affordable and secure way to make
their robotic system aspirin should have
a bachelor degree in computer science
and pursue a career in robotics with
additional training or certification in
automation is advantages robotics
engineers are in high demand with 9000
plus job openings in India and 8 000
plus openings in the US top companies
like Amazon Bosch and flybase are hiring
robotics engine years but salary is as
high as 160 thousand dollars in the US
and rupees 27 lakhs in India next up on
our list we have product manager the
role of a product manager is to
recognize and express user requirements
market research and creating competitive
evaluations and also creating a
product's vision and putting emphasis on
a product strengths and qualities
freshers cannot join as a product
manager it requires basic experience of
two to three years in the field of
product and software development
according to indeed.com an average of
2000 plus jobs are currently available
in India and 20 000 plus job vacancies
are there in the US with top companies
hiring are Tesla Amazon TCS sprinkler
cognizant Etc with a salary as high as
160 000 per year in the US and rupees 20
lakhs per annum in India up next we have
data scientists they mainly deal with
lots of data extraction of Knowledge
from all collected data is the subject
matter of data science it was also voted
the success job of the 21st century good
news is there is no need for any special
degree as a data scientist you need to
have knowledge of machine learning
programming in Python are Java and
mathematical modeling being a fresher
you can join as a data scientist too
data scientists are in demand with 17
000 plus vacancies in the US and 3000
plus vacancies in India and big
businesses like accent enter TCS IBM
Google JP Morgan Deloitte Bank of
America recruiting data employees with
salary going as high as 200 000 per year
in the US and rupees 15 lakhs per annum
in India moving forward in our list we
have ai data analyst data mining data
cleaning data interpretation are the
three main tasks of an AI data analyst
data cleaning allows for the Gathering
of the necessary information for data
analysis and AI data analyst make
inferences from the data using
statistical tools and techniques you
need a bachelor degree in computer
science or mathematics to work as an AI
data analyst to get this job you must
have a thorough understanding of
regression and be able to use Ms Excel
according to indeed.com there are
currently 700 plus AI data analyst jobs
available in the United States and 16
000 plus job vacancies in India with top
companies like Accenture IBM am we Pro
TCS and capgemini recruiting them and
salaries going as high as hundred
thousand dollars per year in the US and
rupees 8.5 lakhs per annum in India the
next stop opportunity in AI is business
intelligence engineer a business
intelligence developer's main duty is to
take both business ends and AI into
account they evaluate complex data sets
to identify various business Trends they
assist in boosting a company's earnings
by planning creating and sustaining
business intelligence solutions to
become a business intelligence engineer
you are required to have a bachelor
degree in mathematics and computer
science according to indeed.com there
are 8 000 plus job available in India
and 5000 plus job vacancies in United
States companies hiring are Amazon
Development Center IBM AWS Etc with this
salary going as high as hundred thousand
dollars per year in the USA and rupees
15 lakhs per year in India coming to the
top three jobs available in AI at number
3 we have machine learning engineer
artificial intelligence is known to
include machine learning it runs
simulations using the varied data
provided and produces precise results
they are constantly in demand from the
businesses and their position seldom
goes unfilled they handle enormous
amount of data and have exceptional data
management skills the ability to code
use computers and understand mathematics
a requirement for success as a machine
learning engineer a master's degree in
computer science or mathematics is
highly preferred the necessary
technological Stacks include python are
Scala and Java a deep understanding of
neural networks deep learning and
machine learning algorithm is very
helpful coming to job opportunities
lastdoor.com predicts 13 000 plus job
vacancies in the US and 27 000 plus jobs
available in India with companies like
mat work Google Amazon Microsoft Azure
IBM Etc hiring them with salary going as
high as 150 000 per annum in the US and
rupees 10 lakhs per annum in India
coming at runner-up position we have
data architect data Architects are it
Specialists who utilize their knowledge
of computer science and database
architecture to assist and analyze an
organization's data infrastructure
fresher graduates cannot become data
Architects a bachelor degree in computer
science and computer engineering or
related subject is the absolute minimum
requirement to become a data architect
data Architects are in high demand with
52 000 job vacancies in the United
States and 7000 plus jobs in India and
top companies hiring data Architects are
Amazon IBM Tesla Intel Wipro with the
average salary quite high as two hundred
thousand dollars per year in the United
States and rupees 21 lakhs per annum in
India and Topping our list of job
opportunities in aies AI engineer AI
Engineers are problem solvers who create
test and use various artificial
intelligence models they manage the AI
infrastructure well to create practical
AI models we use neural network
knowledge and machine learning
these models enable one to gain business
insights which AIDS the organization in
making wise business decisions
ug or PG degree in the field of AI or
computer science is required in addition
to that you can hold certifications from
any reputed organization which will add
up to your resume please check out and
enroll to the AI program by simply learn
in collaboration with Purdue University
the link is provided in the description
below job openings for an AI engineer
are quite high with 35 000 plus job
vacancies in the US and 4000 plus jobs
in India and Tech giants like Accenture
PCS IBM Google JPMorgan Deloitte Bank of
America recruiting them with salary
going as high as two hundred thousand
dollars per year in the US and rupees 10
lakhs per annum in India and this was
all for this AI Basics video hope you
guys found it informative and helpful if
you like this session then like share
and subscribe if you have any questions
then you can drop them in the comment
section below thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here